Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat und ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Ok.
Tja.
Das frage ich mich auch.
Ich verstehe es nicht, warum Grafikkarten-Driver-Settings einen Nvidia-Account brauchen.
Keine Ahnung.
Das frage ich mich auch.
Vielleicht ist es ja in Wirklichkeit.
Remote-Login auf deinem PC für Nvidia.
Das frage ich mich bis heute, warum das so ist.
Kannst du das nicht deinstallieren?
Das ist Bestandteil vom Grafikkarten-Driver.
Also, du kannst das deinstallieren, aber dann kannst du keine Settings mehr machen.
Oh nee, ich muss updaten.
Nein, nein, nein, wir updaten jetzt nicht.
Diese GeForce Experience war früher noch viel ätzender.
Kann sich jemand noch dran erinnern, als die GeForce...
Nehme ich auf oder streame?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist vielleicht die Platte voll.
Kann sich jemand daran erinnern, als die GeForce Experience früher noch Spiele optimiert hat?
Ohne zu fragen.
Du hast ein Spiel installiert, hast es gestartet oder hast da geadded, hast einen falschen Knopf gedrückt.
Ich glaube sogar automatisch ursprünglich.
Und dann hat es Spiele optimiert in Settings, die du überhaupt nicht haben willst.
RobDead, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ah nee, du hast...
Okay, du hast gegiftet für den Ragnar 9.
Ja, exzellent.
Huge Subscription hier.
Massive Sub.
Oh, so früh.
Exzellent.
Ich bin immer krank.
Die Hände sind zu groß mittlerweile durch die ganzen Prime Subs.
Nicht gesund.
Ja, ich bin auch noch müde.
Wobei, ich bin schon, ich bin schon...
Ja, halbe Stunde, noch 40 Minuten, 40 Minuten bin ich schon wach.
Ungefähr.
Wir müssen demnächst unbedingt meine GIF Overlays fixen.
Guckt mal, das GIF ist viel zu schnell.
Das ist so hyper, hyper kacke.
Keine Ahnung, hyper shit.
Und das hier lädt ewig.
Guckt euch das mal an, das müssen wir unbedingt demnächst fixen.
Also die meisten GIFs gehen ohne Probleme.
Gar kein Ding.
Die funktionen ohne Probleme.
Alles kein Thema.
Das hier ist ein Problem, wenn ich das hier anklick.
Hört euch das mal an, ich klick jetzt.
Laggy as fuck.
Und die Transparenz stimmt auch nicht richtig.
Wobei, ich glaube, es hat gar keine Transparenz.
Und die meisten, die meisten gehen schnell.
Und Sachen hier wie...
Wo ist das Klo?
Die sind zu schnell, dabei müssten die eigentlich so sein.
Das müssen wir unbedingt fixen.
Weiß ja nicht genau wie.
Aber gerade das Warten auf so ein GIF, wenn du klickst und musst dann 3-4 Sekunden warten, ist nervig.
Als sich Notepad in Windows 11 passiert, das ist nur...
Nö.
Das weiß man aber auch noch nicht.
Also das, was wir da gesehen haben, das ist ja so eine super Early-Preview-Version gewesen.
Was im Endeffekt heißt, es kann alles Mögliche sein, wenn es rauskommt.
Allerdings, es hat einen Microsoft-Entwickler.
Mal hier, Twitter.
Hey, Notepad.
Es hat einen Microsoft-Entwickler gepostet auf Twitter.
Dass sich das...
War das das?
Ja.
Das hat einen Microsoft, also nicht eher irgendein anderer Typ, ja.
Das hat einen Microsoft-Entwickler, glaube ich, gepostet auf Twitter.
Dass sie Paint und so updaten.
Wobei man mal ganz ehrlich sein muss.
Virtuales Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich sehe es jetzt als 14 oder?
Das ist ja Massive Brain.
Huge IQ Increase Subscription Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wobei das Lustige ist, das sieht ja jetzt schon inkonsistent aus.
Also guck mal, hier haben sie komische Ribbons.
Was ist denn das?
PowerPoint?
Das PowerPoint?
Kennst du dich?
Okay, PowerPoint hat jetzt runde Ecken.
Okay, also Paint kriegt jetzt komische Menüleisten und neue Ribbon-Icons.
Ja, toll.
Und Notepad kriegt eine neue Menüleiste.
Aber das ist doch kein Update.
Das ist einfach...
Wahrscheinlich musst du dafür noch nicht mal am eigentlichen Programm was ändern.
Sachen wie alte Systemsteuerungen...
Nein, nein, nein.
Die werden uns für immer erhalten bleiben.
Die werden uns für immer.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Weil das Problem ist, die können die alte Systemsteuerung ja nicht rausschmeißen.
Es gibt ja noch viele Settings, die nur über die alte Systemsteuerung überhaupt erreichbar sind.
Da kann ich erstmal die Monitorwiederholrate erst seit dem vorletzten Windows-Update überhaupt einstellen.
Über die neuen Settings.
Und es gibt sicherlich noch ganz, ganz viel, was nur über das alte geht.
Zum Beispiel detaillierte Netzwerkeinstellungen oder sowas.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Es ist halt einfach so.
Es ist halt total sinnlos.
Ich hab übrigens schon ein paar Videos aufgemacht, die wir uns gleich angucken.
Genau.
Soundeinstellungen.
Soundeinstellungen gibt's nicht.
Also es gibt...
Moment.
Jetzt vergleichen wir das mal.
Es gibt hier Soundsettings.
Du kannst hier im Prinzip die absoluten Basics einstellen.
Von Lautstärke insgesamt und Input-Lautstärke insgesamt.
Aber das war's.
Okay, das kenne ich noch nicht.
Das fällt mir jetzt zum ersten Mal auf.
Okay, das ist ein Mixer.
Das da ist quasi...
Das da nur in...
In hässlicher...
Wer ist eigentlich auf diese Idee gekommen, dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein schönes Design wäre?
Ich meine, das sieht doch abartig scheiße aus.
Das sieht aus, als hätte irgendein 3-jähriger mit HTML...
Okay, vielleicht übertrieben.
Ein 3-jähriger, der HTML lernt, versucht, eine Setting-Seite zu machen.
Vor allem, warum...
Oh.
An sich funktioniert's.
Aber für die ganzen Settings, also für die etwas advancederen Settings,
musst du immer hier rein, immer hier in das Alte.
Zum Beispiel, was ich manchmal machen muss, ist...
Ich muss manchmal hier rein und das auf die Sample-Rate umstellen,
weil mein Audio-Interface ist auf 48 Kilohertz.
Und...
Manchmal, wenn ich den zweiten Rechner starte, der da drüber geht,
ist es aus irgendwelchen Gründen der Meinung, das muss wieder 44,1 Kilohertz sein.
Dann muss ich das umstellen.
So, und...
Ja.
Diese Settings kriegst du nur über das Alte.
Was witzig war, Modern Warfare hatte mit diesen Settings am Anfang Probleme.
Da ging der Sound nicht.
Du musstest runterstellen auf 44,1 oder umgedreht.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, oder hochstellen.
Okay.
Ja, Leute.
Auf geht's.
Ja, auch nur bedingt.
Auch nur bedingt.
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Rionic Fire ist wieder am Start. Nice.
Da Benzel ist auch wieder da. Pog.
By the way, ich verstehe gar nicht, warum die immer noch so auf Ribbons rumreiten.
Ribbons waren zu Office 2000, was?
Wann wurde das eingeführt? Office 2008 oder so?
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich war noch nie ein großer Freund von Ribbons.
Ich finde aber Ribbons besser als teilweise Menüs, die...
oder was? 2007, ja.
Ich finde aber Ribbons teilweise besser als Menüs, die fünf Seiten lang sind.
Wenn ihr euch das jetzt zum Beispiel mal hier in Wishful Studio anguckt.
Da hast du ja teilweise Menüs, da findest du gar nichts.
Also, fuck.
Und das ist noch wenig. Es gibt auch Menüs, die sind viel krasser.
Also, Ribbons haben schon irgendwie was.
Aber ich bin auch kein großer Fan von...
Manchmal ist es einfach so, dass Software die gewisse Komplexität...
also die komplexe Dinger für dich machen kann, eben auch eine gewisse Komplexität im User Interface braucht.
Weil du es nicht anders unterbekommst.
Das ist ja das, wo sie aktuell ein bisschen Probleme mit haben
und alles weiter vertaplifiziert wird, wie zum Beispiel diese Menüleiste hier von Firefox.
Das ist die bescheuertste Idee aller Zeiten, Alter.
Was hat man sich hierbei gedacht?
Das ist so Paintschamp hoch 10.
Gibt es jetzt wirklich irgendjemand, der das mit Touch hier bedient? Wirklich?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Null.
Weißt du, du musst das unter Advanced einstellen.
Achso, ja, hab ich ja.
Genau.
Ja.
Aber es backt manchmal rum, weil es sich manchmal umstellt auf 44,1.
Ah ja.
Ich finde das neue Firefox Design auch nicht schlecht.
Ich fand aber schon seit sie das eingeführt haben dieses neue Menü hier kacke.
Dieses vertaplifizierte Smartphone mäßig gemachte Menü, obwohl wir hier von der Desktop Anwendung reden.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Firefox krebt sich eh schon.
Also wie nennt man das?
Sägt sich den eigenen Ast schon ab seit ein paar Versionen.
Seit so zwei Jahren oder so.
Okay, ich will jetzt mal aufwachen. Exquisite.
12 Monate Subscription hier schon.
Auch am Start.
Danke schön.
Fünf Monate Sub.
Was für ein Audio Interface hast du am Start?
Ich hab, das habe ich aber schon jahrelang, ein Moto Track 16, nicht 17, 16.
Hier, das sind die extra Anschlüsse.
Das ist eigentlich nice.
Kann man die Inputs routen, wie man will, kann die Sachen zusammen mischen, wie man will.
Hat digitalen Eingang.
Vorne hast du Ausgänge für zweimal Kopfhörer und nochmal zwei Channels Line In.
Und dann hier hast du auch noch zig Anschlüsse. Das ist wirklich cool.
Das gibt mittlerweile sicherlich schon einen Nachfolger.
Ja, hier kannst du auch den ganzen Kram zusammen mixen.
Ich hab mir das damals gekauft, weil ich halt zig unterschiedliche Sources hatte und zwei Rechner.
Und ich auch per XLR Mikro und allem möglichen Zeug aufnehmen wollte.
Also ich hab ja Konsole dran und ich kann das jetzt halt einfach umschalten.
Wenn ich sag, ich brauch Voice vom PC und Sound von der Xbox, dann stelle ich das hier einfach im Mixer ein, easy.
Und dann hab ich das.
Die machen echt ganz gute Sachen.
Was ist denn ein M4?
Du meinst jetzt nicht das Mikrofon, oder?
Das benutze ich bloß nicht.
Ich hab einen Sennheiser MK4.
Das da.
Das Teil habe ich schon seit ein paar Jahren, aber ich verwende das lustigerweise nie.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Achso, Moto M4 zeigt man ja.
Das ist neuer.
Wie gesagt, ich hab meinen schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Das ist bestimmt auch ausreichend für die meisten Sachen.
Naja, wie dem auch sei.
Was kannst du damit auch den Sound von PC und... Jaja, kann ich?
Klar.
Wobei ich hab den...
Den Mix Amp hab ich immer noch dran.
An der Xbox.
Der kannst du da nochmal gesondert einstellen, aber vom Mix Amp gehts dann in das Audio Interface.
Jo.
So siehts aus, Leute.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was ich witzig finde?
Ich hab ja hier...
Ich hab ja letztens vor ein paar Tagen...
Oder ich glaub vor drei Tagen hab ich ja dieses Video gemacht über Windows 11.
Also wo Microsoft das Ganze vorgestellt hat.
Und es sind ein paar richtige hardcore Windows-Fans in den Kommentaren am Start.
Die meisten geben mir recht.
Ich mein mir gehts jetzt nicht so sehr darum, dass mir alle zustimmen.
Auch wenn das jeder natürlich gerne hat.
Aber manche Leute sind schon geil in den Comments.
Du hast den...
Muss ich grad mal raussuchen.
Du hast Leute die schreiben so nach dem Motto...
Nee Max, stimmt nicht was du sagst, aber ich hab jetzt keinen Bock das zu erklären warum.
Dann denk ich mir auch immer, alles klar.
Aber die meisten sehen das ja ähnlich.
Ja, paar Leute sind dringend.
Ja, das halt ich übrigens auch für ein Gerücht.
Das ist die andere Seite.
Der schreibt, es war eine gute Entscheidung auf Linux.
Übrigens läuft jedes Mal einer 36 Spiele auf Linux.
Ich würde echt zu gerne wissen, welche 86 Spiele das sind.
Also wenn die auch nur halbwegs aktuell sind.
Welche 86 Spiele das sind, die absolut problemlos auf Linux laufen.
SuperTuxCard, ja.
Also ich will gar nicht bestreiten, dass es das gibt.
Es gibt sicherlich deutlich mehr als 86 Spiele, die ohne Probleme auf Linux laufen.
Das ist nicht die Frage.
Aber wenn man das als Vorteil anführt, dann sollten da ja auch mal irgendwelche Games dabei sein, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise gespielt werden.
Und wie gesagt, spätestens...
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Wie ist denn das mit CS und Anti-Cheat?
Das geht, glaube ich, oder?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wo du komplett gelitten hast, ist sowas wie wenn du Epic Launcher und solche Sachen brauchst.
Also es läuft mittlerweile viel mehr als früher.
Aber wer problemlos spielen will, der kommt leider nicht an Windows vorbei.
Das ist halt das Problem.
Sonst würde ich doch kein Windows Mal verwenden.
Das ist auch geil.
Das einzige ist wirklich der Unterbau.
Gerade die Integration von Linux und Android PS habe gerade kein Lust, intensiver draus zu gehen.
Also es stimmt nicht, aber ich will es nicht erzählen.
Dass Microsoft Rust übrigens irgendwie großartig einführt oder intern in Windows verwendet, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Da halte ich Microsoft nicht big brain genug für.
Das ist auch geil.
Es gibt irgendwelche Prerelease Benchmarks, die sich sogar teilweise widersprechen.
Du hast Benchmarks, da ist es besser.
Du hast Benchmarks von echten Games mit realistischen Settings.
Dann ist es teilweise sogar eins bis zwei Frames schlechter.
Dann darf man nicht vergessen, dass in diesem Pre-Build wahrscheinlich so gut wie nichts im Hintergrund läuft.
Also da muss man mal auf die Release Version warten, ob das ist.
Ansonsten wäre das ja cool.
Aber das ist jetzt nichts, wo ich sagen könnte, oh ja, da kannst du dich jetzt schon voll drauf verlassen.
Ich hätte ja nichts dagegen, wenn das so ist.
Die hatten wahrscheinlich irgendwie eine Schleife vor IIN 5 Milliarden und haben jetzt einfach eine Null rausgemacht bei Windows 11.
Und jetzt sind sieben Prozent schneller, easy.
Das, wie du das weg machst, ganz einfach.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Du klickst auf deine Taskleiste, gehst auf News und Interests und sagst Turn Off.
Guck, bei dir sieht das so aus.
Ich kann sagen, es funktioniert nicht.
Übelster Crap braucht wirklich absolut keine Sau, um es jetzt mal hart zu sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Test für Windows 11 Widgets.
News und Interests, Turn Off, Bäm.
Dazu kann man nur sagen.
Also wirklich totaler Müll.
Kannst du das später gucken?
Oh nee, das ist NDR.
Nee, die striken mich.
Location liegt OMFG, Alter.
Wobleak.
Leute, ich sehe, dass viele subscribt haben.
Aber ihr verwendet gar nicht unsere GIF Emotes.
Gerade wenn der Stream anfängt, ist das das beste Sack.
Better Twitch TV.
Das ist kein Better Twitch TV Emote.
Das ist ein Channel Emote.
Ach, Moment.
Das ist gar kein Channel Emote.
Ich kann nicht warten.
Das hier ist ein Channel Emote.
Ich habe mich vertan.
Ich kann sagen, ich benutze gar nicht Whoop Arrive, Alter.
Das ist ja gar kein Channel Emote.
Es gibt ja nur die zwei.
Stimmt.
Mist, ich kenne nicht mehr meine eigenen Channel Emotes.
So, also.
Windows.
Kann man in der Emote Vorschau nicht die Animation sehen?
Doch, kann man.
Kann man.
Naja.
So, was gucken wir uns denn heute an?
Ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Vielleicht ist das irgendein Setting.
Also man muss in FFZ, falls du FFZ installiert hast,
da musst du GIF-Animation einschalten, aber das sollte...
Twitch ist kaputt.
Ja.
Das stimmt nicht.
Hast du das mit...
Ja, habe ich mitbekommen.
Habe ich mitbekommen.
Da gucken wir uns auch gleich noch ein Video zu an,
weil der hat wohl irgendwie eine eigene Kryptowährung jetzt,
falls er gestorben ist oder so.
Aber ich habe vorher ein Video gesehen.
Keine Ahnung, was es damit auf sich hat.
Was nutzt du an Hausautomation?
Boah, das kann ich jetzt so schlecht kaum in einem Wort erzählen.
Ich habe einige Lampen.
Ich habe meine Heizung drin.
Ich habe die Thermostate drin.
Fenster, Türsensoren, die Waage im Bad,
Temperatursensor im Kühlschrank.
Vieles, vieles Zeug.
Ja, das ist aber glaube ich nur ein Problem mit FFZ.
Ich glaube, das ist, wenn man FFZ nicht installiert hat,
bei der Twitch-TV geht das standardmäßig.
Die Heizungssteuerung, die sind wir noch aus.
Die sind wir noch aus.
Guck.
Immer noch procken.
Oh, die hat zwischenzeitlich sogar mal irgendwelche Ausfälle gehabt.
Ja, Quaint.
Ich habe es immer noch nicht gefixt.
Ich hatte immer noch keinen Bock zu fixen, das Kabel auszutauschen.
Und Raspberry Pi im Keller.
Obwohl es jetzt schon eine Woche her ist.
Die Waage ist nicht automatisiert.
Also nicht die eigentliche Waage.
Was automatisiert ist, ist, dass es das Gewicht überträgt
in die Heimautomatisierung.
Da habe ich jetzt einen schönen Kraft drin,
wo ich sehen kann, ob ich abnehme oder zunehme.
Heizung, das ist ja, doch brauchst du.
Du brauchst ja auch warm Wasser.
Also, das ist ja Heizung und warm Wasser.
Ja, prinzipiell schon.
Haben wir sogar mal im Stream gebastelt.
Mit Infrarot-LED.
Aber ich schalte die über die Fernbedienung aktuell ein und aus.
Patrix ist HD.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Ich muss mal kurz was trinken.
Ich bin richtig big brain am Pumpen hier.
Nee, ich gehe nicht ins Fitnessstudio.
Aber ich bewege mich jeden Tag so zwei Stunden.
Seit Corona lustigerweise.
Seit eineinhalb Jahren mache ich das jetzt täglich.
Und ich muss sagen, ey, mir tut der Rücken nicht mehr weh.
Ich bin insgesamt fitter.
Ich kriege keine Kopfweh mehr.
Ich kann jetzt auch mal zwei Stunden irgendwo einkaufen gehen,
ohne dass mich das großartig juckt.
Also, das bringt schon was.
Corona hat auch seine Vorteile.
Michael, 50 Billionen, nice.
Und wieder am Start.
Hast du was Neues mit NFC-Tags gemacht?
Nö, ich hatte nur NFC-Tag im Baden.
Ich habe NFC-Tag am Bett.
Der am Bett macht aber noch nicht allzu viel.
Der ist ja dafür geplant,
dass ich dann auch mal Rollo hoch und runter mache.
Das funktioniert prinzipiell, aber habe ich noch nicht eingerichtet.
Und der im Baden gibt es immer noch.
So.
Ja, so kann man das nennen.
Wobei, ich bevorzuge Wandern anstatt spazieren gehen.
Also auch mal mit ein bisschen berghoch und runter
und ein bisschen im Grünen.
Man muss ja nicht immer vier, fünf Stunden wandern.
Man kann auch zwei Stunden wandern gehen, das reicht.
Gerade am Tag nachmittags, wenn man arbeiten war.
Am Wochenende gehe ich meistens auch ein bisschen länger.
Samstagvormittag Wandernvideo.
Stimmt, ich habe sogar ein Video gemacht.
Dort, wo ich immer rumlaufe.
Wobei, was heißt immer?
Stimmt ja gar nicht.
Ab und zu laufe ich da rum.
Ich habe so fünf, sechs verschiedene Sachen,
wo ich immer hinfahre.
Je nachdem, wo es gerade ist.
Ein bisschen flacher und dann ein bisschen...
Klar, das sind Taunus um die Ecke.
Na ja, um die Ecke.
Stückchen.
Wanderstream.
Nein, mache ich nicht.
Mache ich nicht.
Das ist eines der Anlässe,
wo ich tatsächlich mein Auto für verwende.
Im Zug kannst du da nicht hinfahren.
Wanderstream.
Tja, live aus dem Wald, Alter.
So, also was gucken wir uns denn heute mal an?
Zeig es mal her.
Komm, wir lassen uns gleich mal jebaiten.
Wir lassen uns gleich mal von Levelcap wieder jebaiten.
Also Wanderstream, wenn irgendwie...
Wobei...
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das war ja noch mit Schnee.
Ja.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was?
Das muss ich euch mal kurz zeigen.
Es geht mir nicht um den Inhalt des Videos,
sondern eher darum, dass ich in diesem Video was versucht habe.
Ich glaube, das ist keinem aufgefallen.
Und zwar...
Guck mal.
Dieses Video ist auf 1080p...
Ich mache den Sound aus, da geht es überhaupt nicht drum.
Dieses Video auf 1080p 60fps.
So, und jetzt guckt mal, wie weich die Kamera...
Wie weich der Kameraschwenk ist.
Seht ihr das?
Wie weich die Kamerabewegung ist.
So, das geht nur, wenn es auf 60fps aufgenommen ist.
Ich war aber dumm.
Ich war aber dumm und habe es nur mit 30fps aufgenommen
mit meiner iPhone-Kamera.
Und ich habe das hochgerechnet mit FFmpeg auf 60fps.
Ja, genau.
Das ist FFmpeg Zwischenbildberechnung.
Deswegen...
Das hat ein bisschen gedauert.
Also das Video geht 7 Minuten.
Ich glaube, das hat 2,5 Stunden oder so dafür berechnet.
Alle 6 CPU-Cores oder was auch immer ausgelastet.
Aber wisst ihr, was das Coole ist?
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
Man sieht das nämlich manchmal.
Also Schnee und so passt ja alles.
Aber...
Guck, ihr seht es am Rand.
Seht ihr es am Rand?
Checkt das manchmal nicht so genau.
Und manchmal gibt es auch ein paar Artefakte.
Manchmal...
Also gerade hier am Rand sieht man es gut.
Da verschwimmt es.
Jetzt seht ihr das.
Aber ohne Scheiß, Leute, für Zwischenbildberechnung
ist es mega gut geworden, oder?
Also es fällt kaum auf.
Du hast manchmal ein paar Bild-Artefakte drin.
Manchmal seht ihr, dass manche Äste oder so klitschen.
Das ist aber niemand aufgefallen.
Das geht aber glaube ich auch nur,
weil es ein relativ statisches,
nicht zu sehr ändernes Bild ist.
Okay, manchmal klitschen die Äste ein bisschen.
Ja.
Übrigens, das ist so eine Strecke.
Die laufe ich eigentlich echt ganz gerne.
Sowohl im Winter als auch im Sommer.
Geht ein bisschen berghoch, ein bisschen bergunter.
Ist echt pock.
Und um nicht zu vergessen,
wo sind die Monkathos Schneemänner?
Hier.
Bin ich schon beigelaufen, stand ein Schild,
hat irgendwie einer Schneemänner mit dicken Salamis gemalt.
Äh, was heißt gemalt, gebaut.
Sonders männliche Schneemänner.
Naja, gut.
Hubs, ich wollte eigentlich zumachen.
Warum ist es nicht zugegangen?
So, wir lassen uns jetzt mal Jibaiten,
Jibaited von Levelcap.
Super AI.
Ach ja, das habe ich übrigens gar nicht für erwähnenswert gehalten
oder vielleicht habe ich das nebenbei gesagt,
dass man jetzt Battlefield 2042 auch gegen Bots spielen kann,
weil viele Leute ja Angst haben, Multiplayer zu spielen,
weil die Leute alle so toxic as fuck sind, was ja auch stimmt.
Ähm, gibt es jetzt zum practicing Bots, finde ich ziemlich gut.
So, schauen wir mal kurz Musik aus, gucken wir uns mal an.
Lassen wir uns mal Jibaiten, lassen wir uns mal Jibaiten von Levelcap.
Das muss ich nicht lauter machen, das ist eh immer das gleiche.
Ach, Moment, das ist nicht immer das gleiche.
Ich habe den gerade verwechselt, egal.
Aber Jibait, Jibaitcap ist das.
Das halte ich aber für ein Gerücht, dass es keine Cheater in dem Fortress mehr gibt.
Haben die Bots skill-based Matchmaking? Weiß ich nicht, sehen wir jetzt gleich.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ah, mal gucken, lass uns mal kurz gucken, Steam Stats Battlefield 3.
Das ist auch, das ist nämlich auch ein bisschen, guck, das ist auch ein bisschen hochgegangen.
Hier war es kostenlos letztes Jahr, da haben relativ viele, 414 ernsthaft,
die Zahlen sind merkwürdig, ich meine es ist nicht viel, aber ein bisschen mehr ist es trotzdem.
Und hier ist es auch nochmal hochgegangen, wo Battlefield angekündigt wurde,
Battlefield 2042.
Ja, das ist hauptsächlich Origin stimmt, habt ihr recht, ja.
Ich hoffe aber nicht, ich hoffe nicht, dass das standardmäßig ist.
Ich habe keinen Bock, dass die Runde am Anfang losgeht mit Bots.
Oh nee, da musste ich eben mal gucken, hast du jetzt einen Bot gekillt oder einen Spieler.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also man muss ja eins sagen, so wie ich das mit dem Lost Star in dem Video schon gesagt habe,
es sieht alles geil aus, es sind auch geile Ideen, wie sich es am Ende spielt, sei mal dahingestellt.
Also die haben immer noch die Chance das ganz groß zu verkacken.
Bots können nicht ausgebildet werden, okay, toll.
Wie können die, ich wollte gerade sagen, wie geht denn das überhaupt ohne Blockchain und Continuous Delivery
und agilen Meetings und so, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Verticales DIA skalieren, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, ich glaube nicht, dass die Bots haben.
Also zumindest ohne Blockchain geht das schon mal gar nicht.
Ja, dachte ich mir schon, da hat er mit auch recht, gehe ich mal von aus.
Das dachte ich mir aber auch schon.
Ich hoffe halt, die Splitten die Player Base nicht zu sehr.
Es ist besser geworden, ja es ist besser geworden.
Was ist CFHD, ah das ist Crossfire, Alter Crossfire, dass das immer noch überhaupt am Leben ist.
Ah, ne Runde Sellout, ne Runde Sellout, Poggers.
Ja, okay, easy level cap Sellout.
Das muss jetzt nicht sein.
Was, und das funktioniert doch immer noch richtig, oder?
Ja, das haben wir gesehen.
Äh, Intel 8th Gen bedeutet was?
Ist mein 8700K, ist das 8th Gen?
Weil da ne 8 drinne ist?
Ist die 8th Generation, ich hab keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt von Intel Benamung.
Okay, es wäre ja auch hängen geblieben, wenn das nicht so ist.
Ich mein, mein Rechner, der ist jetzt zwar schon, ich mach mich ja da selbst immer drüber lustig,
der ist jetzt ja auch schon fast 4 Jahre alt, aber der ist immer noch performanstechnisch im oberen Bereich
mit einer 1080Ti, 8700K und 32G RAM, da kannst du heutzutage überhaupt nichts dagegen sagen, das ist immer noch super.
Und da mach ich mich ja regelmäßig selbst drüber lustig, dass ein Rechner nach 4 Jahren heute immer noch,
naja vielleicht nicht high end ist, aber nicht viel drunter.
Und früher musstest du dir nach eineinhalb Jahren neue Kiste kaufen.
Da Master Chief.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn Windows 10 noch supportet wird bis 2025 oder so.
Ja, bis dahin hab ich auf jeden Fall einen neuen Rechner, solange man endlich mal Grafikkarten kaufen kann.
Ich wollte mir ja schon letztes Jahr einen neuen kaufen, aber ich konnte ja immer nicht.
TikTok auf Windows, ja klar, es laufen jetzt Android Anwendungen.
Warte mal, diese Games, die da dazwischen drin, okay das ist wahrscheinlich die offiziellen Games, die dafür supportet werden.
Ich frag mich immer, ob der für diese kurzen Einspieler von irgendwelchen Teilen von Game Trailern Geld bekommt.
Weil die sind immer so random zu dem Video.
Okay, Strike, Game ist jetzt schon down, wobei ich hab keine Ahnung, wie heißen die nochmal genau?
From Software, nicht From Software, ich weiß nicht wie die damit umgehen.
Also Nintendo hätte das Ding schon in der Entstehungsphase in den Tod gestrikt.
Okay, okay, wisst ihr warum die das machen? Die wissen wahrscheinlich, dass die Leute zum größten Teil nicht die Hardcore Halo Grinder sind.
Und denken sich, hey besser wir verkaufen ein paar mehr Season Passes, anstatt wir zwingen die Leute dazu das zu spielen und hauen dann komplett ab.
Das muss man sich bei denen immer genau überlegen, das ist keine Entscheidung immer, weil sie so gute Menschen sind, sondern weil sie für ihr Geschäftsmodell den größten Vorteil dafür sehen.
Ich hab gehört, in Warzone gibt es wieder Unsichtbarkeitsglitches.
Ja, so wie immer.
Das machen die jetzt, weil sie jetzt haben es genug Leute gekauft wahrscheinlich.
Okay, Apex juckt mich nicht so wirklich.
Obwohl ich euch ehrlich sagen muss, so doofs klingt.
Von allen Battle Royale Games spricht mich Apex vom Movement und dem ganzen System eigentlich am meisten an, auch wenn ich es nicht spiele.
Ich hab am meisten Battle Royale Warzone gespielt, wobei ich Warzone gar nicht mal so geil finde.
So, Apex spricht mich eigentlich vom Movement und der Sachen drumherum an, aber ich spiele es irgendwie nicht.
Keine Ahnung, Battle Royale ist einfach nicht meins.
Ich glaube im Leben nicht, dass es jetzt cheaterfrei ist.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich verstehe übrigens auch gar nicht, warum Valve das Game so schleifen lässt.
Das hat immer noch eine riesige Fanbase.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber gut, Gabens Wege sind eh schon immer unergründlich gewesen.
Da blickt man nicht so genau durch.
Ich gebe YouTube nochmal eine Chance zu refreshen.
Das Video kenne ich, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, aber das ist auch etwas, was ich auch schon lustigerweise öfters in der Vergangenheit gesagt habe.
Da es so viele Abos gibt, du brauchst ja mittlerweile 5 verschiedene Streaming-Dienste für Videos, 5 verschiedene Streaming-Dienste für Musik, 5 Prime-Abos, 5 hier und da.
Du bräuchst das theoretisch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20 Abos, wenn du wirklich alles gucken willst, was du willst.
Und da sagen sich viele Leute, wisst ihr was, leck mich, ich lad mir den Kram jetzt einfach runter.
Leider sind die meisten Leute immer noch so blöd und machen das Ganze über BitTorrent oder sowas oder irgendwelche P2P-Dinger.
Da wundern sie sich, wenn sie Post vom Anwalt kriegen.
Wie dem auch sei, ich habe glaube ich schon ewig nichts mehr illegal heruntergeladen.
Ich gucke einfach die meisten Sachen nicht.
Aber wenn man das wirklich machen will, du brauchst ja heute total viele Abos und es kommt immer mehr dabei.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen zu der Zeit, ist zwar ein bisschen anders gelagert, geht aber in die gleiche Richtung.
Wenn du den Leuten nicht das gibst, was sie haben wollen, zu irgendwie einem für sie akzeptablen Rahmenbedingungen,
dann gehen die Leute ins Filesharing, dann holen sich die Leute das über andere Wege.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen zu der Zeit, als was gab es an Napster, Audio, Galaxy und sonst was, als die Dinger so im Boomen waren.
Damals hat die Musikindustrie noch gesagt, Leute, wir verkaufen euch die Sache nur auf CD.
Und die Leute haben gesagt, nein, ich möchte es nicht auf CD kaufen.
Erstens nicht für den Preis und zweitens ist CD vollkommen outdated.
Ich will das einfach jetzt haben, sofort runterladen auf meinem PC.
Und siehe da, kaum gibt es Musik-Flatdrains oder Musik-Streaming-Dienste, es funktioniert.
Denen muss einfach wieder ordentlich Geld durch die Lappen gehen, dass sie auf die Idee kommen, wir machen das wieder anders.
Das wird jetzt 3-4 Jahre dauern, dann denke ich, wird sich das wieder erledigen.
Oder aber die Leute werden einfach cleverer, was Filesharing angeht.
Ich hätte es ja nicht für möglich gehalten, auch vor 2-3 Jahren.
Ich habe ja auch so ein Video gemacht, das VPN-Anbieter, dass das eigentlich nichts bringt.
Aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass Filesharing mal wieder so einen riesen Boom erlebt.
Und dafür sind die ganzen VPN-Dinger gar nicht mal so verkehrt.
Natürlich muss man sich immer noch fragen, inwieweit die jeweiligen VPN-Anbieter, wie weit man denen trauen kann.
Wenn die sagen, no logs, locken die wirklich nichts.
Oder was die sonst noch so versprechen, da muss man sich halt überlegen, okay, traue ich der Sache.
Aber ansonsten, wenn die Leute wirklich Filesharing wollen und sich mit der Technik und allem nicht weiter beschäftigen wollen,
mein Gott, kann man so einen VPN nehmen.
Aber ich möchte jetzt hier keinen Anstift zum Filesharing.
Letztendlich, ich Fileshare auch nicht mehr.
Also nichts, nichts Illegales mehr.
Filesharing tue ich natürlich noch.
Oder was heißt nichts Illegales, nichts Geschütztes mehr.
Jo, deswegen, das Video muss man sich angucken.
Okay, YouTube, was empfiehlst du denn sonst noch schon?
Schau ich mal her.
Super billig, News, Steam Sale.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Ich skippe nur kurz durch, weil ich sage, es ist alles, alles sinnlos interessiert mich nicht.
Pass mal auf, wetten.
Okay.
Ghost of, okay, das könnte tatsächlich gar nicht schlecht sein, wenn man sich dafür interessiert.
Ich glaube, das ist echt ein ganz nice Game.
Äh, hallo?
Okay.
Wo ist denn das Steam Sale?
Ach hier, ach hier, das ist nur das Steam Sale.
Ich dachte, die machen jetzt ein ganzes Video drüber.
Kegwaid.
Aja ja.
Okay, unsinnig.
Ah, Lulz, See of Thieves, geh mal fort.
Langweilig.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Also, GameStar macht echt teilweise, teilweise muss ich sagen, die meisten guck ich an, aber teilweise echt gute Videos.
Also, was ich mir ganz gern angucke ist von Maurice, die Videos, wo er sich zur, wie soll man sagen, zur Lage der Gaming Nation immer auslässt.
Legt wahrscheinlich daran, weil ich zu, sagen wir mal so 70, 80% ihm meistens zustimme.
Manche Sachen sehe ich anders, das finde ich ist genau die richtige Mischung.
Wenn du nämlich einem, wenn du zu 80% Sachen anders siehst, dann regst du dich permanent auf, wenn du ein Video guckst, aber das ist so eine ganz gute Mischung.
Du stimmst, also ich gucke gerne Videos von Leuten, denen ich, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, mit denen ich schon zum größten Teil übereinstimme, aber auch die eine oder andere Sache halt eben nicht.
Sonst ist es gar so langweilig, wenn du bei allem immer nur Ja und Amen sagst, aber wenn du Videos guckst von Leuten, wo du alles anders siehst, dann das ist zu anstrengend.
Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Windows 11 kommt, das ist richtig.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz, Microsoft hat die neue Windows Version vorgestellt.
Oder mal gucken, wir müssen uns das Intro anhören, wir müssen uns das Intro anhören, mal gucken, mal gucken, wie nah ich dran war.
Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz, Microsoft hat gestern offiziell, also gestern, je nachdem wann sie das Video sehen, Windows 11 vorgestellt.
Na komm, also jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich war da wirklich ziemlich nah dran.
Also komm, weit weg war ich nicht auf jeden Fall.
Er hat noch ein paar Sätze dazwischen gepackt, ja.
Du hast das Video noch gesehen, ne?
Nur ganz kurz, 17 Minuten, das ist halt die Standard-Zamper-Video, das Standard-Zamper-Video-Intro.
Geld regiert.
Sag mal, bin ich, ich weiß, wenn man das so fragt, weiß man eigentlich, dass man das nicht ist.
Aber bin ich eigentlich der Einzige, den es verwirrt, dass die aktuelle Europameisterschaft 2020 heißt?
Ich gebe immer ein, wenn ich gucken will, ich gucke ja wenig Fußball.
Aber immer wenn ich was gucken will, gebe ich immer ein Euro 2021 auf Google.
Google ist ja so schlau mittlerweile und zeigt dir dann auch Euro 2020 Ergebnisse an.
Wann gibt es den Collaboration-Stream mit Zamper-Video?
Ich kenne Zamper-Video nicht, ich glaube, Zamper-Video kennt mich nicht.
Sieht nicht so danach aus, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viel Überschneidung wir da haben.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich gucke ab und zu mal ganz gern Zamper-Videos.
Ich hätte nichts dagegen, ich würde tatsächlich sogar ganz gern was mit Zamper-Video aufnehmen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es dazu kommen wird.
Über was? Über was sollten wir jetzt?
Über was sollte man jetzt da reden?
Also, mir fällt noch nicht mal ein Video-Thema ein, ehrlich gesagt.
Was könnte ein Video-Thema sein? Habt ihr ein gutes Video-Thema?
Arbeitskollegen? Ja, da lässt er da immer gerne drüber, habe ich gehört.
Da fällt mir nichts ein.
Computer-Fieren?
Ich meine, ich glaube, der ist sogar noch älter als ich.
Weiß man, wie alt der ist?
Also ich meine, ich bin jetzt 36, Zamper-Videos wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung.
47? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie alt der ist.
Bei mir machen die Leute schon immer irgendwelche Boomer-Witze.
Zamper-Video ist zwischen 40 und 50, okay.
Cobalt? Sehr gute Idee.
Easy Way to Breakthrough Metro? Ah, das ist Battlefield 4.
Okay, was ist der Easy Way für Metro?
Einfach Sliden oder was?
Hä? Wo war da jetzt der große Trick dran?
Wo ist da jetzt der große Trick dran?
Außer, dass er null beschossen wird?
Hä?
Was?
Meint er seine Movement? Hä? Wo ist denn jetzt da der massive Brainplay?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Der Trick ist nicht gekillt werden, indem man in die Gegnerflagge rennt. Nice.
Hä? Okay Leute.
Jetzt, jetzt, Pause-Champ, Pause-Champ, bam.
Okay, das war cool.
Okay, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das uns sagen sollte jetzt.
Pause-Champ.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier? Apple.
Warum deine Apps zu teuer sind?
Oh, ne, Simplicissimus kann ich mir jetzt gerade nicht geben.
Das müssen wir später machen.
Das ist bestimmt wieder, lasst mich ran, dieses Video ist sicherlich wieder super dramatisch.
Der macht das ja alles immer so, so zu übertrieben.
Ja, das, das geht jetzt nicht.
Also, John McAfee's Wacked Dead Man Switch, das gucken wir jetzt.
Das habe ich für mich vorher schon gelesen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was, was es da geht.
Also, was ich, was ich, was ich im Vorfeld gesehen habe und mir aber keinen Reim drauf machen konnte.
Es gibt, also der Typ hat irgendein Tattoo, ja.
Es gibt, also, jetzt, als der Typ gestorben ist, es gibt irgendeine Cryptocurrency, die man, die man jetzt, die irgendwie was damit, ich, ich checke es nicht.
Der hat jetzt irgendwie nach seinem Tod, hat er jetzt irgendwie eine eigene Cryptocurrency.
Ich habe es nicht so genau gecheckt.
Also, also, wir müssen mal gucken.
McAfee heißt er, ich dachte immer, er heißt McAfee.
Okay, schlechter, schlechter Joke. Mc, McAfee.
Also, also, was ich bei dem Typ glaube, ist, dass der einen Dachschaden hat.
Dass der einen richtig harten Dachschaden hatte, schon die ganze Zeit.
Was?
Was ist ein Wacked Contract?
Big Brain Blockchain Geschichte. Und was hat der Wacked Contract damit zu tun, dass er gestorben ist?
Also, wie, wie konnte der Wacked Contract sich aktivieren, wenn er gestorben ist?
Also, wie, wie, wie hängt das zusammen?
Hat er, hat er einen Puls Sensor oder was?
Und der Puls Sensor hat dann, oder, oder wie, oder, hä?
Oder ist das so ein Ding, solange er sich nicht innerhalb von so und so viel meldet,
dann aktiviert sich das automatisch oder wie ist das?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung.
Also, mal gucken.
Also, also, also sprich, der Kerl hatte irgendwie online einen, ja, irgendeinen Service oder was auch immer oder benutzt irgendeinen Service.
Und wenn er sich dann nicht regelmäßig meldet, dann aktiviert sich das oder wie?
Das würde mich mal interessieren, wie die Hintergründe sind, weil, weil wer sagt uns denn, dass es von ihm ist?
Also, es kann auch, kann auch genauso gut irgendeinen, irgendeinen Fake Kram sein,
wo einfach nur das dransteht.
Ist das viel?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, was?
Uint 256?
Okay, das hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Uint 64, okay, okay.
128, ich glaub 128 ist echt das höchste der Gefühle, was ich bisher je, aber ich wusste gar nicht, also Uint 256.
Na gut, brauch halt viele Nullen, ne?
Also, was dann jetzt hier?
Ha, ha, was jetzt denn so ne Webseite, what the fuck!
Äußerst vertrauenswürdige WACK-Webseite schonmal.
NARRATOR 2 Uint 243
puzzles
Hintergrund
fight
äußerst vertrauenswürdige Webseite!
Genau so sieht ne Webseite auf, dass ich WACK-Coin kaufen würde oder WACK-Token.
9000 WACKT-Tokens, also wenn du auf den verschiedenen Dexen auf WACKT guckst, wirst du sehen, wie viele 9000 Token aufkommen.
Das sind einfach Leute, die ihren Airdrop verkaufen.
Also mit WACKT, wissen wir, dass es eine große Zeit ist, neue Coins können nicht übertrieben werden.
10% aller Transaktionen werden an eine Burn-Adresse geschickt, was bedeutet, dass diese Coins zerstört werden.
Also wenn du 10.000 WACKT-Token verkaufen willst, dann werden 1.000 WACKT-Token zerstört.
Also, 1 in 10.000 Transaktionen werden die ganze Sache an einer Burn-Adresse geschickt.
Also es gibt 0.1% Chance, dass, wenn du den Token verkaufen willst, alle Coins an einer Burn-Adresse geschickt werden.
Und als Ergebnis von diesen beiden verschiedenen Wegen, in denen die Token von Menschen auf WACKT werden können, ist die Versorgung der Coins bereits von 20% runtergegangen.
Also, dieses Token ist hyperdeflationär, aber behalte, dass es immer noch ein Scheiß-Coin ist.
Es ist ein sehr riskierter Investiment, wie alle Krypto-Koins.
Aber als Scheiß-Coin ist es noch riskierter und es ist auch ein John McAfee Scheiß-Coin.
Also es wird entweder ein wirklich guter oder ein wirklich schlechter Investiment sein.
Aber es ist sicherlich der Scheiß-Coin, um alle Scheiß-Coins zu enden.
Und, um so transparent wie möglich zu sein, seit ich hier über einen Krypto-Asset rede, sollte ich euch meine Investitionen zeigen.
Ich will keine Verbrechen von Sicherheitsverbrechen machen, also bin ich in WACKT.
Okay, ich habe gerade über 27.000 WACKT-Token.
Dieses Coin ist Nummer 1 auf Uniswap und verschiedenen...
Warum sehen diese ganzen Kryptowährungen immer aus wie Scam?
Okay, das ist Material Design Scam, das ist Next Level.
Wahrscheinlich ist es gar kein Scam, aber es sieht übelst, übelst von den Farben, übelst Scamm-y aus.
Und wie deflationär es ist, könnte es viel weitergehen.
Aber, weißt du, nehmt das nicht als finanzielle Hinweise.
Das ist wirklich mehr als Investition.
Ich habe gerade als WIM investiert.
Wie kaufen Sie es?
Willst du dir einen Metamask-Kreis und finanzieren ihn mit einigen Effekten?
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Ich habe es einfach mit einem Metamask-Kreis investiert.
Also, ich bin wirklich ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Wie kaufen Sie es? Willst du dir einen Metamask-Kreis und finanzieren ihn mit einigen Effekten?
Also, du brauchst Ethereum, um WAPT zu kaufen.
Wenn du es nicht schon hast, kannst du es kaufen.
Du kannst es als Doge kaufen.
Was hat er denn sonst noch gemacht?
Was hat denn er damit zu tun?
Ach nee, da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Eigentlich ist mir das auch ziemlich wurscht, was bei dem abgeht oder abging.
Mario XCB, Dankeschön für die 5 Monate, das Subscription.
Ok, YouTube hat nichts gescheites, oder?
Rare PS4, was?
Rare?
Wo ist das?
Wo ist hier?
Rare PS4?
Wo stand das?
Wow, da ist überhaupt nichts rare.
Hier, Rare PS4 Unboxing.
Ok, das machen wir jetzt.
Der ist gut, von dem guck ich mir auf das mal was an.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt im Schnelldurchgang an, was da so rare dran ist.
Schau mal irgendwas von Linus Tech Tips.
Wir haben in der Vergangenheit öfters mal Linus Tech Tips geguckt, aber ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
die letzten Videos oder generell die ganzen Channels, die damit zusammenhängen,
es gibt wenig, was mich interessiert, was da in letzter Zeit produziert wird.
Hyper Please.
Back in 2014, Sony released the 20th Anniversary PlayStation 4.
Now this was a fairly rare and exclusive PS4.
I wouldn't say it's the rarest PS4 that you can get.
Rare?
Ich kenn bloß hier den Rare Parrot.
Was braucht man eine Rare PS4?
Die kann bestimmt PS1 abspielen.
Ok, zeig her.
Sieht aus wie DualShock.
Der Knopf sieht anders aus.
Ich find meinen PS4 Controller nicht, aber der Knopf sieht farbiger aus.
Naja, ich mag den DualShock nicht.
Xbox Controller beste.
By the way, dieses Touchpad. Hat die PS5 dieses hässliche Touchpad überhaupt noch?
Ja, echt?
Stimmt.
Ok, sieht aber anders aus.
So wirklich sinnvoll war das ja selten.
Das sieht echt toll aus.
Wenn wir den originalen Controller vergleichen, sehen wir, dass die Farbe-Schemen...
Ok, das ist für Hardcore-PlayStation-Fans.
Ok, es hat die gleiche Farbe wie die ursprüngliche PS1, alles klar.
Aber wenn man das unbedingt haben will, also wenn man das wirklich ganz furchtbar schafft,
draußen im Zweifel dann male ich einfach meine PS4 an.
Weil das Gehäuse ist ja ziemlich gleich.
Die Farbe-Scheme ist nahe, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nicht ganz richtig.
Vielleicht hat es mit meinem PlayStation-System zu tun.
DIY-Perks, ja da haben wir letztens ein Video von geguckt, wo er irgendwie einen Rechner eingebaut hat in einen Schrank oder so.
Da war ich jetzt nicht so richtig begeistert von.
Aber guck, du hast deine Ethernet-Porte und die Portfolie.
Was ist eigentlich los?
Du hast 6 PS4-Firmware.
Auf 1.7...
Ok, braucht absolut kein Mensch.
Aber ok, es ist halt einfach eine PS4 in PlayStation-1 grau.
Das kann nur Sammler-Kram sein.
Wobei ich habe halt ganz starke Zweifel, dass Konsolen eine sinnvolle Wertanlage sind.
Ich glaube die einzige Konsole oder Spiele und Konsole mit der das funktioniert aktuell ist ein NES mit dem original Super Mario.
Das ist glaube ich das einzige, was heute irgendwie oder eines der wenigen ist, die heute mehr Wert ist als ursprünglich, wo man das kaufen konnte.
Ein Gameboy?
Nee, Gameboys gibt es immer noch total viele.
Gameboy.
Ich habe meinen Gameboy leider weggeschmissen.
Nö.
Oder bei bin ich?
Doch, ich glaube schon.
Ich habe meinen Gameboy leider irgendwann mal weggeschmissen, nachdem ich den irgendwie 15 Jahre nicht verwendet habe.
N64.
Ja, mein N64.
Ich war ziemlich dumm.
Ich war ziemlich dumm damals.
Also als ich umgezogen bin 2013 habe ich meinen N64 weggeschmissen und meine Wii weggeschmissen und ich glaube auch meinen Gameboy weggeschmissen.
Das einzige was ich aufgehoben habe ist mein Super Nintendo, weil der war nicht dort in der Wohnung, der war schon hier.
Und ich habe noch, ich glaube Mario 64 und Ocarina of Time habe ich noch original hier und ein paar Super Nintendo Spiele,
aber ansonsten habe ich den Rest nicht mit umgezogen.
Wait what?
Ja!
Painschamp, ne?
Richtig, Painschamp.
Naja, ihr müsst euch überlegen.
Also heute ärgert es mich, dass ich es weggeschmissen habe, ja.
Aber ihr müsst euch überlegen, ich habe das Ding damals ja auch schon 13 Jahre nicht mehr angehabt.
Warum soll ich den Ollentechnik-Scheiß behalten?
Naja, jetzt ist es weg, zu spät.
Zu spät.
Was hältst du von den ganzen deutschen Pewtee Technik, was ist das?
Ein Pewtee Technik Channel?
Felix Baer ist doch kein Pewtee Technik Channel.
Also das ist einer der wenigen Leute auf YouTube, den ich tatsächlich persönlich kenne,
das ist doch kein Pewtee Technik Channel.
Oder meinst du mit Pewtee Technik Channel, dass der halt eben sehr drauf achtet,
dass das stylisch gefilmt ist und hauptsächlich Apple-Produkte oder was?
Ja dann, dann verstehe ich, dann verstehe ich.
Eyecandy, ja das ist richtig.
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich interessiere mich wenig für den Content an Smartphones.
Den Kerl selber, wie gesagt, ich kenne nicht viele von YouTube persönlich,
ihn kenne ich zufälligerweise persönlich.
Also überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit, fand ich echt nett.
Ansonsten, ich gucke das nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich interessiere mich für Smartphone-Content nicht.
Okay, Alexi Bexy kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Alexi Bexy kann ich mir auf Dauer nicht anschauen, das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Kennst du ein Privacy OS für den Raspberry Pi, was meinst du damit?
Das Standard Raspberry Pi OS ist Privacy genug?
Oder du meinst damit, wo irgendwo Tor Browser oder so mit drin ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt es Tales für den Raspberry Pi?
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Divorce Speedrun.
Der Typ hat teilweise echt lustige Videos.
Okay, was können wir uns als nächstes...
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt mal die äußerst dramatische Geschichte erzählen,
warum deine Apps zu teuer sind bei Apple.
Nachdem es ein Simplicissimus-Video ist, wissen wir, es wird äußerst dramatisch.
Mit dramatischer Betonung, dramatischer Musik
und vor allem aus nicht dramatischen Sachen werden dramatische Sachen gemacht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wieder total übertrieben, warte mal ab.
Also auf gut Deutsch, Epic hat versucht noch mehr Geld zu machen.
Und Apple hatte was dagegen.
Auf der anderen Seite, das muss ich denen mal anrechnen,
Epic Games hat das definitiv nicht aus einer reinen Nächstenliebe gemacht.
Da sind wir uns ja, glaube ich, einig.
Die Sachen, die daraus entstanden sind,
mit Diskussionen mal um den Share und den Anteil von Storebetreibern
und dass sich da ja zumindest in letzter Zeit auch ein bisschen was tut
und jetzt mit Microsoft, mit ihrem Store, die da auch was abfahren wollen,
das finde ich wiederum gut.
Epic Games selbst ist das natürlich rein um die eigene Kohle gegangen.
Anzeige ist raus.
Die wussten das ja schon, das war ja alles geplant.
Die wussten genau, dass Apple sie rausschmeißt,
beziehungsweise sie sind davon ausgegangen, dass Apple sie rausschmeißt.
Die hatten quasi im Vorfeld schon ein halbes Jahr
da wahrscheinlich irgendein Rechtsanwaltkanzlei dran arbeiten.
Und die haben das dann einfach nur noch gesagt, okay, jetzt schickt's ab.
Ja, das finde ich auch wieder so ein Ding.
Muss man da wirklich die eigenen Spieler für instrumentalisieren?
Klar, natürlich bringt Epic was, aber das ist halt so typisches Fanboy,
wo man eben als Fanboy ausgenutzt wird.
Das denen, die da keinen Bock drauf haben, ist mir klar.
Ja, ist er.
Man muss schon was zu sagen.
Alter.
So.
Es ist ein bisschen zu vergleichen, also ich hab da rechtlich gesehen, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist ein bisschen damit zu vergleichen,
wie als Microsoft damals den Internet Explorer gebundelt hat, wartet mal.
Alter, irgendwas im Hals.
So, also, letzter Stream.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Mist.
Fuck.
Und was hab ich da angefangen?
Ach so, ob das illegal ist, genau.
Also, das ist ein bisschen was, wie als Microsoft den Internet Explorer gebundelt hat.
Aber damals hieß es ja, Microsoft nutzt das Monopol aus,
was sie mit Windowsnummer haben auf dem Desktop,
um ihren eigenen Browser durchzusetzen.
Der Unterschied zu Apple oder dem Google Store ist,
dass es ja nicht heißt iPhone oder Android, sondern dass es heißt Smartphone.
Und auf Smartphone betrachtet gibt es ja Alternativen.
Du kannst dir ein Apple-Gerät holen,
du kannst dir ein Android-Gerät in unterschiedlichen Facetten holen,
du kannst dir ein Fire-Gerät holen,
du kannst dir, wenn du ganz hart drauf bist, auch irgendwie ein Titzen, Tritzen, wie auch immer das heißt,
holen oder irgendwie ein Nischen-Gerät.
Also, das gibt es ja.
So monopolmäßig wie Microsoft damals auf dem Desktop ist das Smartphone technisch nicht.
Wenn man jetzt natürlich die Einzigen, wie gesagt, ich hab recht nicht keine Ahnung, wie das ist.
Es ist so meine Ansicht dazu.
Wenn man jetzt allerdings die Plattform an sich sieht, dann ist es natürlich klar,
Apple erlaubt neben Apple nichts.
Und Google ist auch kein großer Fan davon.
Also Google hat ja glaube ich auf Amazon auch nicht wirklich Bock und umgedreht.
Also die stehen alle auf geschlossenen Plattformen.
Allerdings ist halt die Frage, ob das illegal ist, weil du weißt ja im Endeffekt auch,
also du entscheidest dich ja bewusst für, es ist ja nicht so als musst du ein Apple-Smartphone kaufen
oder als musst du ein Amazon-Smartphone kaufen.
Du hast ja die Auswahl und du weißt im Vorfeld auch, was da auf dich zukommt.
Das ist wie, wenn du sagst, hey, warum erlaubt Spotify auf Spotify
nicht noch einen anderen Anbieter als Spotify oder so in der Richtung.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das illegal ist.
Ups, nein, nein, ich will nicht auf mein Shield-TV-Kasten.
Warum sollte ich das machen?
Warum muss dann Amazon keine 30% an Apple abdrücken, wenn ich da...
Hä?
Warum sollte Amazon was 30% an Apple abdrücken müssen?
Oder du meinst, wenn du Amazon-Anwendungen im Apple-Store kaufst?
Oder was?
Amazon muss das gleich, Amazon muss das abdrücken,
also wenn Amazon im App-Store was verkauft,
dann müssen die das gleich an Apple abdrücken wie alle anderen auch.
Oder aber sie haben Custom-Vertrag mit Apple.
Ach, du meinst, wenn ich... Ach, Moment, jetzt verstehst du.
Du meinst, wenn man die Amazon-App über den iOS-Store runterlädt
und dann in der Amazon-App was kauft,
weil du die App, weil das kein Content,
also ich vermute mal, dass das so argumentiert wird,
ich weiß es nicht genau, weil du kein Content für die App kaufst,
sondern du benutzt die App, um Dienstleistung zu bestellen,
das ist wie, wenn du in der Lidl-App was bestellst,
oder in HelloFresh, oder wie das heißt,
deinen nächsten, keine Ahnung, Koch-Bundle bestellst oder so.
Oder Lieferando oder so was.
Hm.
Also wenn es nach Apple geht,
wenn es nach Apple geht, müsste das wahrscheinlich auch so sein,
aber es ist zum Glück nicht so.
So, okay, okay.
Bei Fortnite war es ja genauso.
Genau, da ging es um In-Game-Content für die App.
Deswegen will Apple was anbieten,
deswegen will Apple was abhaben.
Aber ich vermute mal, dass das gar nicht so eindeutig ist,
weil die Bedingungen sind ja absichtlich total schwammig geschrieben.
Meine Güte, was habe ich denn heute im Hals?
Ich hab mir richtig denken, ich hätte hier richtig Gachibars letzte Nacht.
Aber wie gesagt, diese ganzen App-Store-Dinger sind schwammig.
Also man kann App-Store-Bedingungen nicht eins zu eins,
wie jetzt irgendwie Gesetzestext lesen.
Also kann man schon.
Aber die sind alle immer sehr schwammig.
Guckt euch beispielsweise mal die YouTube-Nutzungsbedingungen an.
Es geht überhaupt nicht um meine Logik.
Es geht ja darum, wie Apple das Ganze auslegt.
Und das ist absichtlich nicht so,
es ist absichtlich schwammig.
Guckt euch die Benutzungsbedingungen von YouTube an.
Das ist alles absichtlich schwammig gemacht,
dass man es im Zweifelsfall,
das ist ja auch ein Kritikpunkt, den ich an dieser ganzen Geschichte habe,
das kannst du übrigens auf YouTube, Twitch und alles übertragen,
dass du es im Zweifelsfall so auslegen kannst, wie du willst.
Also realistisch gesehen,
kann dich, ich weiß, es gibt ein paar Gegenbeispiele zu,
kann dich YouTube, Twitch, Apple, wer auch immer,
heute ohne jeglichen Grund bannen
und du kannst so gut wie nichts dagegen machen.
Es gibt ein paar Leute, die haben erfolgreich dagegen geklagt.
Das ist aber eine ganz, ganz kleine, kleine Minderheit.
Und da muss man sich die Umstände mal genau angucken.
Es ist leider so, dass diese Regeln auf diesen Plattformen
sehr vage, also absichtlich vage formuliert sind,
dass man es immer auslegen kann,
so wie es dem Betreiber am besten gefällt.
Das sagt natürlich, ja.
Wer eine App auf seinem iPhone installieren will,
kommt nicht um den App Store herum.
Und bei jedem Verkauf kriegt Apple hier 30...
Leider, leider kommt man da nicht drum herum,
denn auf Android kannst du die Sache noch halbwegs sideloaden.
Das geht auf iOS nicht richtig.
Du kannst auf iOS sideloaden,
aber es löscht sich nach 7 Tagen automatisch.
Also von wegen, du bist her über dein eigenes Gerät.
Prozent Provision.
Dasselbe gilt, wenn etwas innerhalb einer App verkauft wird.
Egal ob Tokens oder Skins oder Upgrades oder Tinder-Boosts,
Apple kriegt 30 Prozent von allem.
Bei Abos ist es etwas komplizierter,
aber auch hier verdient Apple substanziell mit.
Mit den Teilen der Provision hält der Konzern seinen Store in Stand,
überprüft neue Applikationen
und garantiert die Sicherheit bestehender Apps.
Dennoch ist der App Store wohl unfassbar profitabel.
Experten schätzen, dass er 2020
mehr als 12 Milliarden Euro Gewinn eingefahren hat.
Stonks.
Das wäre knapp ein Viertel des Gesamtgewinns von Apple.
Stonks, aber richtige Hardcore-Stonks, ja.
Die 30 Prozent Provision wurden ursprünglich
aus dem Konsolenmarkt übernommen.
Mit dem Verkauf von Konsolen
wird nämlich häufig kein Geld verdient.
Ragemen, die wollen das überhaupt nicht besser machen.
Die finden das gut, dass das so schwammig ist.
Die finden das gut.
Die machen das ja absichtlich schwammig.
Gesetze sind ja, klar sind Gesetze auch in teilweise Auslegungssache,
aber ein ordentliches Gesetz sollte, denke ich mal,
ohne dass ich in irgendeiner Art und Weile rechtlich vorgebildet bin,
möglichst wenig Interpretationsspielraum bieten.
Klar gibt's das, aber es ist ein Unterschied,
ob du ein Gesetz schreibst und möchtest, dass es möglich klar ist,
aber das nicht hinbekommst, oder ob du AGBs schreibst
und diese absichtlich möglichst schwammig formulierst.
Ja, stimmt, das ist richtig, man kann das Ganze jailbreaken.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch was, was garantiert
von Apples Benutzungsbedingungen nicht erlaubt ist,
aber da können sie insofern nichts dagegen machen,
weil du hier rechtlich gesehen machen kannst mit deinem Gerät, was du willst.
Die können aber sagen, sie bieten keine Garantie mehr an,
das können sie machen, aber sie können nicht dafür verklagen
oder nicht davon abhalten, das Ganze zu machen.
Natürlich können sie versuchen, dir Steine in den Weg zu legen.
Das machen sie ja auch.
Oft machen die Hersteller sogar Verluste.
Erst durch die Beteiligung an den Gewinnen von Spieleentwicklern
wird man dann profitabel.
Aber das bei Apple natürlich nicht so.
Das iPhone kriegen sie nicht umsonst, weil die sagen,
wir wollen dann hinterher mit den Apps das Geld verdienen.
Das ist Prof. Dr. Justus Haucup.
Ach der?
Er ist Professor für Volkswirtschaftslehre
an der Heinrich-Heine-Universität Düsseldorf.
Ich hab schon nie gehört.
Außerdem ist er Gründungsdirektor
des Düsseldorf Institute for Competition Economics.
Wenn das so wäre, wenn sie sagen würden, wir verschenken ja die iPhones,
würde man sagen, dann ist 30% vielleicht okay.
Aber es ist mir nicht bekannt, dass sie die iPhones verschenken.
Laut Epic Games CEO Tim Sweeney
könne man mit gerade einmal 8% Provision einen profitablen, sicheren App Store betreiben.
Worüber sind sie vor allen Dingen auch?
Wär gut.
Also die Aussage...
Ich will gar nicht mal sagen, dass das unrealistisch ist.
Aber die Aussage jetzt, dass Epic-Mans,
die ja quasi die Kontrahenten von Apple in dem Fall sind,
da als... Also wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Wenn jetzt Apple versus Epic ist
und Epic sagt, nee, nee, Apple braucht da nur 8% für,
und Apple sagt, nee, nee, wir brauchen da 30% für,
dann ist das eine eine Aussage aus der Sicht...
Der Befürwort ist eine Aussage aus der Sicht der Gegner.
Die sind beide Parteien daran beteiligt, denn würde ich beiden nicht glauben.
Wobei Epic Store angeblich wirklich weniger nimmt als Steam, glaube ich.
Hab ich irgendwo mal aufgeschnappt.
Ich weiß es aber nicht, ob das stimmt.
App Store betreiben.
Worüber sich vor allen Dingen aufregen ist,
dass wenn wir dann hinterher so In-Game- oder In-App-Sales haben,
dann müssen wir immer wieder diese 30% zahlen.
Für jeden Token, für jede Münze...
Es ist doch ganz einfach.
Es ist doch in dem Fall ganz einfach.
Spielt einfach den Kack nicht auf dem Smartphone,
sondern auf dem PC, da wo man eh ordentlich besser
und Master-Raciger spielen kann.
Ist doch ganz einfach. Ganz einfach.
Smartphone-Games spielen.
Smartphone-Games ist eh der größte Scheiß aller Zeiten.
Einfach auf dem PC...
Einfach PC-Master-Race spielen.
...muss man wieder 30% zahlen.
Da ist doch eigentlich gar keine weitere Leistung mehr dabei von Apple.
Dass Apple damit durchkommt,
hängt auch mit der Größe des Unternehmens zusammen.
Rund eine Milliarde Menschen besitzen ein iPhone.
Die Zoomer haben kein PC, aber so Pech.
Dann müssen sie eben Teil der Master-Race werden.
Der Markt ist nicht iPhone.
Aus meiner Sicht ist der Markt nicht iPhone,
sondern der Markt ist Smartphone.
Das sind doch andere Anbieter.
Apple sagt natürlich...
Na gut, das ist klar.
Die Leute brauchen ja kein iPhone.
Es gibt so viele Telefone, die sie sich kaufen können.
So viele Smartphones.
Das würde ich auch so sehen, ja.
Irgendein anderes Gerät.
Da können sie ja den Android-Appstore nutzen.
Und da können sie nicht nur den Playstore von Google nutzen.
Da können sie auch so viele andere Appstores nutzen.
Wenn sie sich ein iPhone kaufen,
dann haben sie doch gar kein Mono.
Genau mein Gedanke.
Ein was?
Das denkt ihr.
Was meint ihr, wie viele Leute sich aus den unsinnigsten Anlässen
ein Handy kaufen?
Das ist ja erst mal wurscht, was die feststellt.
Also Apple hat natürlich den Monopol auf iOS.
Was die erst mal feststellen, ist jetzt glaube ich nicht verbindlich.
Ich bin der Letzte, der damit Probleme hat,
wenn die Sachen im Appstore billiger werden.
Sogar bereits einen Gesetzentwurf,
der unter anderem das Appstore-Monopol angehen soll.
Er soll allerdings frühestens 2023 in Kraft treten.
Ja gut.
By the way, jetzt wo ich das hier sehe,
was ist eigentlich mit dem Abschaffen der Sommerzeit geworden
oder der Winterzeit mit der Abschaffen der Zeitumstellung?
Was ist eigentlich aus dem Abschaffen der Zeitumstellung geworden?
Weißt du was?
Nur mal zum Thema, wie schnell die bei der EU immer sind.
Die wollten das vor zwei Jahren oder so machen.
Und es waren auch alle dafür.
Es wurde sogar eine Umfrage gemacht.
Und jetzt kriegen sie es wieder nicht gebacken.
Das ist so ein unflexibler statischer Bürokratiehaufen.
Das ist unglaublich.
Wenn das Gesetz werden würde,
dann müsste Apple andere Appstores zulassen, auch für iPhone.
Das würde für mehr Wettbewerb auf dem iPhone sorgen.
Kunden hätten mehr Auswahl an Apps und Appstores.
Ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich,
aus meiner Sicht bräuchte es das noch nicht mal.
Eine ordentliche Funktion zum sideloaden von Apps würde schon reichen.
Könnte man Apps ordentlich sideloaden,
dass sie sich nicht wieder löschen und sowas?
Vollkommen in Ordnung, es würde reichen.
...Apps und Appstores.
Apple könnte natürlich weiterhin die Bedingungen für die Appstores festlegen.
Was allen klar ist,
Apple darf durchaus den Appstores weiter Vorschriften machen,
was gewisse Sicherheitsstandards angeht.
Dass sie natürlich nicht anfangen können,
da irgendwelche Viren in das Apple-Universum zu importieren.
Es bleibt abzuwarten,
dass in der Prozess Epic Games vs. Apple in den USA ausgehen wird.
Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt drauf.
Bleibt es bei den 30 Prozent Provision?
Ich wäre ein bisschen überrascht, muss ich zugeben,
wenn die Richter nachher zu dem Schluss kommen, dass das okay ist.
Apple ist kleinen Entwicklern Ende 2020 bereits entgegengekommen.
Sie müssen seitdem nur noch 15 Prozent Provision abdrücken.
Neben Epic Games haben sich auch Facebook, Airbnb und Spotify
öffentlich über die Macht des Appstores beschwert.
Sind das gute Menschen, hä?
Über die Macht des Appstores beschwert.
Epic Games klagt auch gegen Google.
Auf Android-Handys gibt es zwar Alternativen zum Play Store.
Diese Alternativen würden laut Epic aber deutlich benachteiligt werden.
Na klar.
Die Debatte rund um Apples Appstore verdeutlicht,
wie schwer es ist, große Tech-Unternehmen zu greifen und zu regulieren.
Apple bietet nicht nur Smartphones und Computer an.
Der Konzern hat über Jahre hinweg
ein voll integriertes, scheinbar kundenfreundliches Universum
aus Produkt- und Plattformen und Dienstleistungen kreiert.
Alles profitiert voneinander.
Ist man einmal darin gefangen, kommt man nur schwer wieder raus.
Das stimmt, das ist das, was mir persönlich bei Apple
auch ein bisschen auf den Sack geht.
Dass Apple eben am besten mit Apple und weiter mit Apple funktioniert.
Darin gefangen kommt man nur schwer wieder raus.
Die Konsequenzen sind vielleicht subtil.
Aber ganz konkret ist dein Spotify-Premium
vielleicht ein paar Euro teurer als es sein müsste.
Vielleicht lässt du für dein postpandemisches Tinder-Game
etwas zu viel...
Ach so, das war mir leider zu Summersprache,
aber ich hab's noch verstanden.
Also wenn Corona vorbei ist,
und man dann wieder Tinder links-rechts swipen kann...
Ja, ja, okay.
Und vielleicht könnten deine scharmerfüllten Candy-Crush-Käufe
auch etwas günstiger sein.
Denn du bist es, der hier letztlich verliert.
Der ganz normale Nutzer.
Cheers.
Das ist richtig, aber als würde Facebook und Spotify
und Epic Games irgendwas für den normalen User machen.
Du hast recht, du verlierst in der Regel als normaler User
immer bei sowas.
Dass die anderen jetzt allerdings die Welt retten wollen,
hab ich so meine Zweifel.
Aber übrigens das Beste ist,
und auch wie man als normaler User nicht verliert,
kein Mobile-Shit spielen.
Mobile-Games sind einfach kacke.
So.
Deswegen muss man auch mal sagen,
ich finde dieses Apple-Paket, wie heißt denn das?
Dieses Apple-Gaming-Pass.
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Apple Arcade.
Ich finde es vom Ansatz her gar nicht schlecht,
weil es eben dazu anregt,
nicht die üblichen Mobile-Sell-out-Micro-Transaction-Spiele zu machen,
sondern wirklich Spiele, die für den Inhalt stehen
und nicht für Moneygrind.
Zumindest die Chance dafür bieten, ja.
Was macht eigentlich die Diablo Immortal?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Wie sieht es da eigentlich aus?
Geschlossene Alpha Deck.
Ist das die richtige Seite?
Die sieht so nach Scam aus.
Nee, das ist die richtige Seite.
Pre-Register now.
Alpha, wo ist die Alpha? Ich brauch hier.
Oh, geschlossene Alpha seit April.
Alles klar.
Dev-Update.
Okay, ich muss die Bewertung gucken, Leute.
Ich muss die Bewertung auf YouTube angucken.
Interessiert ja viele Leute.
Moment, das ist Diablo.de.
Sekunde, das ist Diablo.de.
Das juckt doch eh keinen.
Das juckt doch eh, das ist doch egal.
Nein, ich will das nicht auf Deutsch.
Alter.
So vielleicht?
Jawoll.
Ja.
Sieht sehr beliebt, immer noch beliebt ohne Ende.
Oh man.
Keg, wait.
So, next.
Schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Ich muss mich jetzt wieder übelst warm ey.
Ich muss gerade schon ganz kurz Klima-Lare anmachen.
Jetzt mach ich ein bisschen, bisschen die Wärme raus.
Puste der Marsch wieder aus.
So, was macht Stadia?
Stadia macht aktuell eher das hier.
Helled Loose Can-ish habe ich noch nicht gespielt.
Okay, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Red Bull Can Open Slash.
Oh, neues Slash-Resistant-Back-Video.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Wollen wir wetten?
Es ist nicht Slash-Resistant.
Guck mal, das ist Slash-Resistant dadurch, weil sie Metall-Aufkleber
oder Metall-Aufdrucke auf dem Stoff haben.
Dadurch wird es Slash-Resistant.
Ich werde die Mechanismen manipulieren.
Nun, es gibt zwei Dinge, die bemerkbar sind,
wenn es um den Ausfluss, den ich benutze,
auf diesem Modus.
Zuerst ist es ungefähr so schnell, als es einfach zu öffnen.
Und zweitens, das einzige Tool, das ich benutzen muss,
ist ein kleines Stück von Red Bull Can.
Lass mich dir zeigen, wie einfach es ist.
Mit dem Lock öffnen, kann ich dir zeigen,
was da drin geht.
Ich nehme diesen kleinen Sliver von Red Bull Can,
und setze es zwischen einem Code-Wil und einem Lock-Body.
Und du kannst sehen, dass ich mich auf dem Lock-Body
drunter drücke.
Wenn es in der gepressten Position ist,
wird dieses Lock öffnen.
Also, lass mich dir zeigen und probiere es wieder.
Dies ist aktuell geschlossen.
Du kannst diese kleinen Tabs nicht drücken.
Ich werde mein Stück von Red Bull Can insertieren,
drücke es runter, drücke auf die Tabs.
So schnell, dass wir es öffnen können.
Lass uns das noch einmal tun, damit du siehst,
dass es kein Fluch war.
Du kannst es nicht wiederlocken,
ohne die korrekte Kombination inzulocken.
Also drücke ich das Locking-Bar aus dem Weg,
damit wir es wieder locken können.
Wieder locken.
Und wieder auslocken.
Okay, Leute.
Je nachdem, wie einfach diese Produkte sind,
um zu öffnen, bin ich nicht sicher,
ob dieses Ausflug wirklich einen praktischen Unterschied macht.
Aber es zeigt sicherlich,
wie wenig Effort in den Design ging.
Okay, ich dachte, er macht wieder Slash-Resistance,
aber es ist immer so, dass ich mir die gleichen Videos angucke.
Was ist denn, wenn ich YouTube sage?
Will ich nicht.
Ich soll mir diese drei Videos angucken.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Refresh.
Jetzt muss ich überlegen.
Oh, YouTube.
Jetzt weiß es nicht mehr weiter.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Jetzt ist es gecrashed.
Pricked.
Okay, wieder die gleichen Videos.
Hä?
Ich habe das jetzt erst erkannt.
Das ist ein Bögeleisnis.
Okay, das ist echt gut.
Okay, das ist echt gut gewesen.
Das Video, nice.
Was gucken wir uns jetzt jetzt an?
Was ist denn das?
So solche Videos gucke ich normalerweise gar nicht.
Warum habe ich das auf?
Ich glaube, das wurde mir empfohlen.
Das ist so ein typisches Video,
wie aktuell total angesagt ist auf YouTube.
Kennt ihr diese Pressenvideos?
Die 50.000 Tonnen Presse versus Bundstifte.
Gibt es total viele mittlerweile auf YouTube.
Die haben was meditatives.
Will it blend?
Na gut, die gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Doch, der hat letztens ein Video gemacht.
Inside the world's largest data center.
Impossible Skip Destroys Portal 2 Speedrun.
Das müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Das wollte ich mir nämlich die ganze Zeit schon angucken.
Die zeigen den Serverraum vom Flugzeug.
Man muss sie nicht labern hören.
Muss man nur sehen.
Da rauscht es größer.
Den Serverraum vom Flugzeug zeigen sie da drin.
Das wollte ich mir schon die ganze Zeit angucken.
Der Boden sieht original so aus, wie bei uns im Flur.
Genauso mit dem Teppich und dem alten Gebäude.
Genauso mit diesen Klappen.
Sieht nach Bürobohnen aus.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man im Flug reingeht?
Wahrscheinlich nichts, oder?
Man muss ja mal reingehen können, wenn was kaputt ist.
Und liegt.
Okay, kann man irgendwas erkennen?
Okay, hier haben sie jede Menge Racks stehen.
Ich vermute mal, dass das normale 19 Zoll Racks sind.
Man erkennt das mit dieser Breitbildkamera nicht so schnell.
Aber sieht aus wie ganz normale.
Ein bisschen kleinere Miniatur 19 Zoll Racks.
So, was sieht man sonst noch?
Okay, wie in jedem Rechenzentrum viele Netzwerkkabel und grüne Dinge, die blinken.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde lieber hier drinnen fliegen als in der normalen Klasse in einem Sitz.
So, super. Ich bin eh gerne im Rechenzentrum.
Ich fühle mich da wohl, passt.
Und es ist schön klimatisiert wahrscheinlich.
Ich würde mir einfach hier eine Isomatte hinlegen und dann stehe ich wieder auf, wenn ich angekommen bin.
Easy.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Sieht man hier irgendwas? Kann man die Auflösung ein bisschen höher machen?
Das hier ist einfach nur ein Schrank da vorne, oder?
Das ist ein Schrank mit Ersatzteilen, würde ich sagen.
So, und hier ist halt irgendwelche, ja, man erkennt es nicht so genau.
Irgendwelche Netzwerk-Server-Geschichten drinnen, man, keine Ahnung.
Man erkennt es nicht so wirklich.
War das da unten so eine Art Playcenter?
Sind das hier so eine Art Playcenter?
So was hier, guck mal.
Das könnten allgemein so eine Art Playcenter sein, ne?
Hier, guckt euch das mal an.
Na gut, platzsparend ist es halt.
Erstmal flashen, richtig.
Ok, Storage-Kram.
Ok, das ist sicherlich nicht safe, während dem Flug aufzumachen.
Ok, das ist bestimmt nicht safe, wenn man das aufmacht, während man fliegt.
Man hat von abgesehen, dass da ziemlich kalt drinne ist.
Was, da sind Tiere?
Da sind doch keine Tiere drin, oder?
Wat?
Alter, wenn ich da mal eine Katze reinmachen würde, die wäre RIP danach, vor lauter Panik.
Alter, die Hunde drehen doch durch dabei, oder?
Die kriegen wahrscheinlich vorher irgendwelche Beruhigungspillen, dass die pennen.
Ok, jede Menge Kabels.
Leider erkennt man nicht wirklich großartig was, muss ich sagen.
Also zumindest nicht für mich als Flugzeugnoob.
Das sah aus, da zwischendrin sah aus wie Playcenter, was wir da unten hatten.
Aber ansonsten jede Menge Kabelställs.
Steht da DHL daneben?
Steht da ein DHL-Flieger daneben?
Das ist einfach nur irgendein Luftsichtschutz.
Sonnenschutz, kein DHL-Flieger.
Die Musik immer dabei, die hört sich immer so super happy an.
Ah ja, guck hier, das wird runtergestellt.
Aber da sieht man ja gar nichts, das ist ja einfach nur sinnloses Werbevideo.
Containerschiff?
Ja, bestimmt noch.
Also komm, wir gucken uns das an.
Beste Battlefield 3 Topplays.
Wir haben uns lange keins mehr angeguckt.
Ok, ich predicte was passiert, da schießt er in den Luft und schießt den Heli ab.
Alles andere ergibt jetzt keinen Sinn.
Und?
Jawoll, war klar, war klar.
Gecommoded Version von Battlefield 3.
Flugzeug, langweilig.
Was sonst, was sonst?
Hier sieht man schon, dass Battlefield 3 ein bisschen alt ist.
Guckt euch mal an, dieses super eckige Ding hier von der Startbahn.
Warum der Typ das kommentiert, verstehe ich auch nicht so genau, zumal er immer das Gleiche sagt.
Und ich sage in jedem Video, dass er immer das Gleiche sagt.
Apus shells, Apus shells, jawoll.
Bam.
So muss das sein, genau.
RPG.
Oh, dass der da genau reinfliegt.
Das ist sowas, das ist so Dinger, wenn das nicht Setup ist, wenn sowas random passiert,
das ist einmal pro 1000 Spielstunden.
Gut, das habe ich auch schon, jetzt mal ohne Mist, das habe ich auch schon geschafft, allerdings,
allerdings, nicht als Pilot.
Also mit dem RPG was abzuschießen.
Bam.
Kommt auch vor, wenn man Support spielt, Support ist ja ein bisschen underrated in Battlefield 3.
Also heute hört er sich ja besonders inspiriert an beim Reden.
Das haben wir schon 30 Milliarden mal gesehen, ich will ordentliche Infanterie Plays haben.
Ich will gebashed sehen, ich will sehen, wie gebashed wird.
Oh ne, nicht der Typ wieder.
Der Kel, der den ganzen Tag nichts anderes macht, wie auf den Maps zu stehen und irgendwelche
Longshots zu geiern, zwei Stück pro Runde.
Alter, der labert immer den gleichen Kram, ey.
Schon wieder.
Oh, huge Background hatte das Spiel damals hier.
Vor allem vergrößert, Pongas.
Der Typ trägt absolut nichts zum Rundengewinn bei, gar nichts, der macht ein Kill pro Runde.
Moment, also, vielleicht ist hier auch Setup, weiß man ja nicht.
Ne, wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal Setup.
Oh, der war, der war nice.
Mal ein bisschen was anderes.
Schau in die Chatbox.
Wo?
Steht, schreibt doch gar keiner was.
Zurück.
Letztes Mal Chatbox ist hier.
Weil es den Typ da rumflamet oder was?
Ne, egal jetzt.
Massive Snipe.
Was?
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Den hat er doch nicht einmal gesehen.
Was zum?
Seht, seht ihr da was?
Ok, ok, Moment, Moment.
Windows-Taste.
Ups.
Plus.
Ich brauch den Zoom, Leute, ich brauch den Zoom.
Wo ist ein Gegner?
Da ist nichts.
Das?
Moment, weg.
Das, das da, ist das ein Gegner?
Ok, Chat Big Brain.
Oh, wie schalte ich denn das jetzt wieder aus?
Ah, nicht.
Ah, er wieder, ok, das ist ein guter Clip.
Da weiß man schon gleich, dass es ein guter Clip ist, wenn er am Start ist.
Alter, da werden sie geschreckt.
Und der Gegner checkt nichts wieder, gar nichts, aber so muss das sein.
Und er rennt lieber auf ihn zu, anstatt ihn zu killen, aber richtig pogger Streak.
Richtig nice, richtig nice.
Ah, trotzdem richtig nice.
Aber die Gegner kriegen, seht ihr das?
Die sind wieder voll, die sind voll im Spawn und werden weggefickt.
Die haben alles, guck mal, 1141, 110.
Scheint mir eine äußerst ausgeglichene Runde gewesen zu sein.
Guckt's euch an.
Alle auf einem Haufen, ja, so hat man das doch gerne, so hat man das gerne.
Was ist denn, was hat denn der für ein Foff?
Das sieht mega, mega fett aus, oder ist das einfach nur eine riesen Auflösung?
Nice, nice, nice.
Bäm, zack.
Der hätte sich nicht bewegen dürfen, der Typ.
Das ist Console Gameplay, oder?
Das ist Console Gameplay.
Das Battlefield 3 Gameplay, PS3, PS3 Gameplay.
Da spielen noch Leute auf der PS3, nice.
Ich kann Klettung, ja.
Ist es übrigens heute ein Rätsel, wie ich das drei Jahre spielen konnte, oder so?
Auf der Xbox.
Gut, der ist ja direkt auf ihn zugeflogen.
Das hätte sogar ich eventuell getroffen.
Das jetzt wiederum nicht.
Wer captchert ein PS3? Gar kein Ding, Capture Card.
Ich hab angefangen 2010 auf YouTube, da haben die Leute noch versucht mit dem Handy den Bildschirm abzufilmen.
Ich hatte damals eine Black Magic Capture Karte und danach eine Elgato Capture Karte.
Deswegen, deswegen haben das die Leute glaube ich auch überhaupt geguckt, weil das wenigstens gescheite Quali war.
Das Ding, ja du musstest ja damals, weil die PS3 über HDMI kein Capture erlaubt hat.
Bam, so muss es sein.
Die ganzen kleinen Kakelinubs müssen gebashed werden.
Ja heute kannst du mit Quali alleine nicht mehr punkten, weil Quali alleine, also heute hat eigentlich fast jeder halbwegs gute Quali.
Geht eigentlich gar nicht anders.
Glaubst du VU wäre für ein anderes Battlefield besser angekommen?
Nee, die haben das, die haben, VU ist, eigentlich ist das ein richtig geiler Mod und das spielt sich sogar besser als auf den offiziellen Servern.
Aber die haben es, die haben es an einer Stelle finde ich verkackt und das ist auch, das hat auch mit dazu beigetragen.
Die hatten keine offiziellen Servern, die hatten zwei offizielle Servern, brauchen einfach auch drei.
Ordentliche Modselection, ordentliche Moderation, ordentliche Administration, das war das Wichtigste.
Leider war das nicht so.
Okay das, what the fuck?
War das, der hat einfach random in die Luft geschossen.
Also so ist es in Battlefield 3 mit Plau, also Plau-Filter und noch Plauerem Video, das ist ja, das ist noch Plauer als sonst Plau Battlefield 3.
Excellent.
Kung YouTube letzte Chance, letzte Chance, letzte Chance uns was zu empfehlen.
The Bad, the Horrible, ja, The Good, bin ich mal gespannt was da wirklich rauskommt.
Das ist das, das ist das, ich dachte das ist Vikings Leute, das ist, das ist, das ist das türkische Vikings hier oder sowas in der Richtung.
Es sah auf den ersten Blick original wie Vikings aus, es ist aber nicht, es ist, die kennen die Osmanen Season 2, kein Stimmer.
Ich hab echt gedacht das wäre irgendeine Szene aus, der Typ sieht auch noch so aus wie der, der Typ in der Mitte sieht von meinen original aus wie ein Vikings Mensch.
Wie heißt der, wie heißt der, wie heißt der Vikings Typ, ich weiß nicht.
genau also der tut und es sieht es sieht übelsehlich aus auf dem auf dem screenshot
naja aber es hätte ich nicht gedacht dass das dass das nicht viking ist aber gut das
ist die osmanen variante von vikings können wir bettel für vier moment ja ja ja klar kann
man richtig viele spieler hast du schon mal escape vom tarkov probiert was alpha 4 games
hat ein video wo war gar nicht hat er wo ist alpha 4 games video
ne das haben wir doch schon geguckt das haben wir doch schon geguckt das ist worauf es sich
über die waffen nach lade animationen und so auslässt mal wieder bf3 bf4 stream ja klar warum
nicht ist das mit problem nicht noch free doch stau bf4 ist gerade free so also hier gibt
es wieder nichts neues zu empfehlen alles material ok ich muss ich will mir jetzt einfach
nur angucken wo gekattet wird wo wird gekattet ich will mir nicht das ganze video angucken das
ist das gar weil in der regel in der regel ist es nämlich so die labern so lang und hier
ok wo wird fast gekattet moment das soll das härteste material sein oder oder was
das kommt ja auch ein bisschen auf den druck an ok wo wird geschnitten wo wird geschnitten
jetzt wird gekattet genau
jetzt schreckt wo wird gekattet jawoll mehr kattet mehr katt zeige es ist klar
ich kann schon unangenehm wenn man nicht finger drunter hat
ok ok wo wird das wo wird das eigentlich gekattet ich will jetzt sehen wo massive
massive cut ist jetzt auf geben uns geben uns volle pulle jawoll und ist es durch
das ist durchgekattet ok exzellent weiß nicht warum es jetzt aber jetzt wissen wir bescheid
jetzt wissen wir wie wir das nicht ganz so härteste material der welt wie das aussieht
wenn man das mit wasser durchdurch schneidet ja nur das obliteration kaum noch einer spielt
in battle field 4 aber youtube ist nicht also der youtube algorithmus ist nicht so wirklich
in der lage mir sachen vorzuschlagen die ich gucken will oder 1000 euro strafe für besuch
beim treten das habe ich das habe ich gelesen in den news dass die polizei nun irgendwie
geldstrafen verhängen darf oder so gegen leute die die dort verwiesen wurden schon mal und
sowas aber was da abgeht ist ja auch nicht mehr normal ein weiterer grund warum man eventuell
nicht seine adresse liegen sollte vor allem wenn man jemand ist der umstritten ist ja
das dorf hat ein verbot vor ausgesprochen sich vor dem haus aufzuhalten ich meine muss
ich das muss jeder auch mal in die anwohner rein versetzen das ist irgendwie so ein kleines
furz dorf mit frag mich nicht 50 einwohnern oder so und die haben eigentlich gar keinen
bock drauf dass da permanent irgendwelche leute hin hin pilgern und krach machen also
das kann ich schon nachvollziehen dass das dorf da kein bock drauf hat wenn bei mir einer
im hof steht und nachts um drei uhr schreit da hole ich meine armbrust raus und dann schreit
er nicht mehr easy problem gelöst wird nie einer merken hell yeah genau oder es schreit
lauter na gut es ist so eine schnellschuss armbrust kein problem easy nachgeladen und
dann zack oder ich hole den speer genau aber da muss ich ja runter in hof nene ich nehme
lieber meine armbrust so next nene den speer dann brauche ich ja in hof runter nene nene
so was gucken wir denn jetzt i ranked every battle ok ich ich renke ich renke auch mal
jedes battlefield game wir gucken uns das video nicht komplett an wir gucken uns einfach
nur an die das end ranking ok wir gucken uns nur das end ranking an weil weil eigentlich
interessiert mich überhaupt nicht was er was er rankt ok das end ranking also ich ok
wir haben aber battlefield tierlist das war jetzt mal mal jetzt selbst mal bettel viel
tierlist also create your own rating alles klar also dann dann rate dann raten wir mal
fehlen da nicht ein paar ok was ist das bettel viel free to play keine ahnung habe ich nicht
gespielt warte mal kurz ein bisschen größer bettel viel oder sachen wir mal so ich kann
es ich kann es nicht einschätzen ok fangen wir mal mit den teil an ich gespielt hab zu
wind an und kurz sehr sehr wenig gespielt sehr sehr wenig gespielt für die damaligheit mega geil sehr aber
sehr wenig gespielt kann ich kann ich eigentlich gar nicht so viel zu sagen aber ich würde mal
sagen allein schon weil das der quasi es ist 1942 und 1943 hier kein 43 dabei dann hat es
auf jeden fall verdient weit oben zu sein so bettel viel fünf sagt habe ich gar nicht
spiel bettel viel eins in ordnung aber auch nicht mein favorit keine ahnung bettel viel zwei muss
ich ehrlich sagen ich habe bettel viel zwei so gut wie nicht gespielt ich pack die beide hier
rein weil ich kann dazu so gut wie nicht sagen amazing amazing hartline ich mein so scheiße war
hartline in manchen sachen gar nicht aber es hatte keine langen zeit motivation so
was das bett company vietnames
oder noch war die bett company das ist gut das ist gut da fehlt doch die hälfte da fehlt die
fucking hälfte games was ist denn das kein pc1 und sonst wie war es dabei ok ist hier mehr dabei ok
das sieht besser aus das sieht besser aus alles klar create your own ranking ok das sieht besser
haben wir den kamer löschen die lied
die lied so das reicht das reicht das reicht ok also heroes kein schimmer 43 war ok für ein
arcade game so fünf gar nicht mein fall direkt f tier beste
dahin hartline also hartline ist gar nicht ultra trash hartline ist in ordnung aber hartline hat
sich nicht so durchgesetzt so dafür top free to play braucht kein mensch keine ahnung brauche
ich nicht kann ich wenig zu sagen das würde ich tatsächlich moment was ist das moment was ach das
ist irgendein add-on kein schimmer bett company kommt auf jeden fall hier oben mit dabei wo ist
wo ist bett company 2 aber der add-on war auch gut bett company 2 kann auch da oben mit dabei
zum rest kann ich eigentlich nicht all zu viel sagen wenn ich ehrlich bin ja komplett so tierlist
easy easy so sieht so sieht meine bett für tierlist aus hartline war eher rainbow six naja
hartline haben so ein bisschen die geilen spielmodi gefehlt konquest auf das einzige
gut spielbarer konquest war die war die füßten map und das aushängeschild dieser bankraub modus
der hat halt gesagt bämm haben wir tierlist gemacht ok schauen wir uns mal seinen ranking an
ok was hat der für ein final ranking was ist das a battlefield 4 on das ok battlefield online das
habe ich ganz vergessen das war das erste battlefield released von da auf der glaub auf der xbox das
oder nee noch mal was anderes keine ahnung weiß ich gar nicht was es ist play for free vollkommen ok
dass das da ist das ist auch ok das ist auch ok das ist auch ok hartline bc1 ja kann man machen
wobei ich ganz ehrlich ich würde bett company 1 auf die gleiche stufe hier mit dem mit dem kram
stellen bett company 1 hatte auch super super rushmaps es war halt bett company 1 ist definitiv
schlechter gealter als bett company 2 so battlefield 1 auf a kann man machen ich meine es ist eine
tierlist letztendlich aber hier sind wir uns einig hier sind wir uns einig ich würde sogar s plus
tier machen battlefield 3 und s tier nur battlefield 4 aber ok das ist geschmacksfahre exzellent kann
man verstehen ok let's input lag let's allow dpi versus high dpi analysis dann analysieren
mal der macht der macht immer gute videos mal gucken ob es auch gut ist
ja schwachsinnig also die haben 32.000 dpi oder sonst was 800 ich habe 800 überall
100 dpi ist natürlich 100 dpi dann brauchst du den ganzen schreibtisch um dich einmal um die
hälfte zu drehen gut kommt auf die in game sense an natürlich
da unten hat er eine auslösung für seine messungen dran
ok ok ok ok was hat er denn da gebaut und das muss ich mal kurz angucken das ist ein motor
nee das ist einfach das also ich würde sagen das ist das ist das ist halt ein ding was doch
das wird ein motor sein oder was dieses brett schiebt wo das mousepad drauf ist also sprich
die maus bleibt statisch aber das maus pad das bewegt sich unter der maus dass da oben ist
einfach nur zum fest halten und da hat er mit ein paar wago klemmen eine kamera am monitor
ach nee das ist die wago für den für den für den strom für den motor
zum glück ist das ein deutscher das ist wirklich sehr praktisch in dem fall dann macht er diese
dinger wenigstens nicht in ounces inches und sonstigen komischen freedom units sondern in
normalen einheiten die man auch versteht und in österreich ist egal irgendeiner der ordentliche
einheiten verwendet ja gut ja gut ok das ergibt doch eigentlich auch sinn wenn man
sich überlegt dass so ein maus sensor ja im prinzip ja übertrieben zu sagen eine art kamera
ist die den untergründ die die untergrundbewegungen registriert dann verstehe ich dass es eben schneller
reagiert bei einem höheren dpi weil du einfach kleinere bewegungen brauchst also muss eine
kürzere strecke zurücklegen dass der sensor eine bewegung erkennt soweit in meinem brain jetzt
zusammen aber wahrscheinlich stimmt das überhaupt nicht und und dementsprechend ist wenn ich
jetzt auch so genau überlege wenn er den wenn er die platte schneller bewegt dann sollte das auch
weiter runtergehen weil es geht ja um die um die strecke also in welcher zeit die die strecke
zurückgelegt wird und dann ist es wahrscheinlich dann mit einer niedrigen dpi zahl wenn die maus
schneller bewegt wird ist das auch niedriger weil der sensor dann halt in kürzere zeit mehr
untergrundbewegung registrieren kann also würde mich wundern wenn es andersrum wäre und das hier
ist klar dass es irgendwann auch mal aufhört ja ja hast du das linus tech tipps video von gestern
gesehen nicht schickt mal link habe ich nicht aber die meisten sachen von linus juckt mich nicht bei
letzter zeit ja gucken wir dann
das ist doch jetzt wo die platte schneller bewegt wird oder ja siehst du sage ich doch sage
ich doch wenn sich das schneller bewegt dann geht es runter genauso habe ich mir das auch
vorgestellt weil der sensor also wenn das so funktioniert vielleicht hat es auch ganz andere
gründe als wie ich mir das jetzt eben zusammen gereimt habe aber wenn der sensor eben beänderung
auf boden erkennt oder der sensor ist eine kamera der erkennt wie viel sich der untergrund bewegt
hat und wenn du schneller bewegt machst natürlich in kürzerer zeit mehr strecke und oder die gleiche
strecke in kürzerer zeit also es geht schneller unten drunter vorbei und dementsprechend braucht
der sensor dann auch kürzer das zu registrieren so weit von der theorie her das ende von linux
ist nahe so so ist das so wer sagt das
sieht das sieht so ähnlich aus wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe was ich ich flicke nur
die ganze zeit super akkuret akkuret nur hier bamm bamm bamm headshot only gar kein problem
alles alles headshot only easy deswegen habe ich ja in overwatch auch immer helden gespielt
wo man nicht zielen muss das wäre einfach unfair gewesen habe ich nicht aufgepasst
das sagt was brian lunduk lunduk ich habe keine ahnung wer das ist klingt logisch klingt logisch
aber mal davon abgesehen ich spiele auf 800 dpi also juckt mich das alles nicht mein 100 dpi
spielt ja wahrscheinlich wirklich keiner das kleinste was ich kenne sind leute die spielen 400
und 800 ist eigentlich so mit das verbreitetste
800 ist gut 800 ist gut
ja von der theorie her wäre es besser da hast du recht toaster es macht aber wenig
unterschied ab 800 dpi hast jetzt ja gesehen und auf der anderen seite brauchst du dann erstmal
ein game wo du die sense so weit runter stellen kannst dass du mit sagen wir mal 1000 1600 3000
was dpi überhaupt auf seine gewünschte in game sense kommst
standardmäßig immer auf sechs lassen ja gut das kann man machen ja aber insgesamt
dieses video ich finde die tests von immer richtig cool insgesamt ergibt das aber natürlich sinn
dass umso schneller du es bewegt und dass es ab 800 aufwärts immer weniger sinn macht das passt also
im prinzip fazit ist eigentlich kaum einer muss was an seinen settings ändern so was sollte ich
mir angucken eben ok was was hat was für ein video ist da jetzt so toll dass wir das gucken
müssen also zeig mal ja dort die wei 16 minuten dort die wei manufacturers are downgrading your
pc machen sie das die lehnungstechtipps videos sind teilweise ein bisschen jebait also
ich weiß nicht wie jebait das ist hoffentlich macht er wieder werbung für die unterhosen in
seinem job nicht job shop ok das ist sehr laut
oder
Weil, da, hier sind die Grafen.
Und.
Das ist schneller.
Aber, schaut euch das an.
Und.
Wir werden diese RAM-Stöcken wechseln.
Und wir werden sehen, ob das ändert.
Interessant, oder?
Auch wenn wir einmal in das System gedrückt haben,
alles über diese sieht total identisch aus.
Das heißt, bis du das machst.
Interessant.
Also das eine in dem Intel-System hat acht Chip.
Und das andere in dem AMD-System hat nur vier.
Auch wenn du...
Anzeige ist raus.
Das eine in dem Intel...
Hat bestimmt jemand abgelötet und mit heim genommen.
Das Intel-System sagt, ein Rang von acht.
Und das andere in dem AMD-System sagt, ein Rang von sechzehn.
Es ist unklar, ob diese kleine Veränderung zum Memory Modus...
Die sind jetzt auf AliExpress, die Dinger, genau.
... wird die Norm vorwärts gehen.
Oder, wenn es zu den weltweiten Chip-Systemen geht.
Moin, Kio Kron.
Aber was wir sicher wissen, ist, dass...
... die Veränderung der Memory Modus so eine Unterschiede zu der Leistung macht,
dass, ehrlich gesagt, wenn du mir vor einer Woche gesagt hättest,
dass es so wäre, würde ich dir nicht glauben.
Ich hätte dir Balderdash gesagt.
Und ihr könnt mich auch nicht glauben.
Also...
Lass mich zeigen.
Jetzt...
Unterschiedlicher Rahmen hat unterschiedliche Performance.
Wahnsinnserkenntnis.
Ich habe die Sachen schon mehrere Mal gedreht,
abgelöst, bla bla bla.
Wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse.
Aber...
... das ist mein erster Mal, es tatsächlich zu erleben.
Also ich bin nicht...
Ich meine, ich habe seine Worte für es, aber...
Jetzt etwas zu bemerken ist, dass, während ich das erwarte,
um AMD zu helfen,
um diese bessere Memory zu machen,
bin ich nicht unbedingt sicher, was zu erwarten von Intel.
Weil eine der Theorien ist, dass,
wegen der Art, wie AMD...
Das Volume-Add-on, das heißt, äh...
Moment.
Volume Master.
Das ist aber nicht sonderlich gut,
weil das kann nicht über...
Also das geht nicht über die Windows-Sound-Regelung,
sondern nur intern im Browser.
Also das heißt...
Das ist ja gar nicht seine Küche.
Das ist ja die Fake-Küche.
Das ist ja ein Studio, in der sie eine Küche haben.
Ähm...
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Das Add-on, das ist nicht gut, weil das übersteuert hat relativ schnell.
Down-Craden würde doch nur heißen,
du kaufst den Rechner und er wird mit der Zeit langsamer.
Das wäre Down-Craden.
Wenn ich den Rechner kaufe und ein anderer Rechner
mit fast ähnlichem RAM ist schneller,
ist das doch kein Down-Crad.
Jetzt, das ist wirklich interessant, es sieht so aus, als wäre es nicht ganz so einfach,
dass vier Chips schlecht, acht Chips gut sind.
Denn schau dir das an.
Das Intel-System mit den x16-Memory-Modulen in dem System
hat ungefähr die gleiche Latenzierung wie vorher,
aber verursacht einen bequem Schuss auf die Memory Bandwidth.
Das würde erklären, warum der Cinebench-Score weniger ist.
Aber dann das AMD-System.
Es bekommt einen bequem Schuss auf die Bandwidth.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ryzen profitiert sehr von schnellem RAM.
Wie gut sind deine Augen, dass es zwischen 250 und 230 FPS-Linus gibt?
Nicht sehr.
Dieser ist mehr wie in den Gamer-Mode-Boosted.
Du kannst mehr Details sehen in den Schatten und so weiter.
Das könnte ein Teil des Tuning-Prozesses sein, den sie durchgeführt haben.
Ich stimme mit diesen Tuning-Prozessen nicht mit.
Ich meine, wir haben uns eine 20% Unterschiede in der Leistung versprochen, nicht wir?
Boah, haben wir das noch mal vermittelt, meine Damen und Herren.
Das ist eine direkte Roll-Reversalung.
Das AMD-System ist nun 10% schneller als das Intel-System,
anstatt die andere Seite zu sein.
Ja, das AMD-System hat den RAM-Sport.
Ich meine, ich kann es jetzt nicht so genau erklären, was der Unterschied ist dazwischen.
Ich meine, okay, es sind unterschiedliche RAM, ja, aber
downgraden bedeutet doch immer noch, wenn ich eine Kiste kaufe und die bekommt 800 Punkte
und ein Jahr später bekommt sie nur noch 700 Punkte.
Das wäre ein downgrade in dem Sinn.
Also...
Das ist das Intel mit dem RAM.
Was?
Diese Frame-Zeiten, also die Peaks sind nicht fast so hoch, wir bekommen...
Wow!
Schau dir das an!
Ich meine, die Latency ist halt abgefuckt, ne, guckt euch das mal an!
Das heißt im Endeffekt, das eine ist quasi so eine Budget-Variante von dem RAM, ohne
dass man das nicht richtig erkennt.
Das ist quasi wie, wie früher bei Druckern oder sonst was, wo du Produktbezeichnungen
hast, die 16 Stellen lang waren und am Ende ist bei dem einen ein A und bei dem anderen
ein B und es sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Geräte.
Wow, es ist wieder passiert, verdammt, ich hatte das wirklich nicht erwartet.
Deswegen, deswegen kaufe ich ja auch nur RGB-RAM, der ist ja aus Prinzip schnell.
Jetzt ist ja nicht der gleiche Motor, Turbo Dead End, es ist ja nicht der gleiche Motor,
es ist ein Motor, der genauso heißt, bis auf die letzte Produktbezeichnungs-Seriennummer-Stelle,
das ist ein anderer Motor.
Es sieht auf Papier so aus, als hätte ich den gleichen, habe ich aber nicht.
Ok.
Das ist eine große Leistungspflicht für das Intel NVIDIA System,
bis man die Erinnerung in das AMD System aufbaut und plötzlich ist es in der Spitzungsdichte.
Das ist nicht zu sagen, dass es keine Exzellenzen gibt.
In DiRT 5 zum Beispiel gibt es sehr kleine Leistungsdifferenzen,
die von einem Typen der Erinnerung zu einem anderen gehen.
Und die Leistung ging tatsächlich ein bisschen runter mit unseren x8 Erinnerungsmodulen.
Das ist seltsam.
Es könnte sein, dass dieses Spiel die Latenz auf unserem AMD System sensitiver ist,
aber es könnte auch sein, dass es ein moderneres Spiel ist, mit moderneren Techniken für die Erinnerung.
Denken an diese Theorie ist Forza Horizon 4.
Was ist der Anreiz für einen Hersteller, den Budget RAM einzubauen, wenn er doch ein Gaming Notebook verkaufen will?
Weil letztendlich interessiert ja den Käufer nicht, was auf dem RAM drauf steht,
sondern einfach nur, was das Ding...
Ja Moment mal, Geld sparen, das ergibt ja keinen Sinn.
Geld sparen ergibt ja keinen Sinn.
Der normale Käufer interessiert sich überhaupt gar nicht, für was da für ein RAM drin ist.
Der will Performance haben.
Und wenn das Ding keine Performance hat und den Test deswegen scheiße abschneidet, kauft er sich das nicht.
Das muss nur schnell wirken.
Was heißt denn schnell wirken?
Du machst einen Benchmark, du spielst ein paar Dinge, stellst fest, es ist schnell, okay, es ist langsam, es sackt.
Auf der anderen Seite, ja gut, wenn man Test Samples, das ist natürlich was anderes.
Wenn man Test Samples verschicken würde und in Tests ist es gut und später schlecht, das wäre natürlich dann schon ziemlicher Beschiss.
Klar macht der Noob Benchmarks, der Noob guckt sich Tests an, bevor er sich was kauft.
Wenn sich jemand ein Test in ein Gaming Notebook kaufen will, dann guckt er sich ein Test an und wenn dieser Test auch nur halbwegs kompetent durchgeführt ist, sind auch ein paar Benchmarks drin.
Und wenn die Benchmarks sich gut sehen, kauft er sich ein anderes Notebook, also ich sehe den Vorteil für den Hersteller nicht.
Es sei denn er faked und schickt den Testern ein besseres Notebook als es am Ende ist.
Der Noob schaut keine Tests her, dann ist es aber auch kein, dass er ein Gamer Notebook kauft.
Gut, wenn es danach geht, wenn einer nur nach Zahlen kauft, dann ist das jetzt aber nur wirklich nichts Neues.
Das gab es ja schon früher, dass der Mediamarkt gesagt hat, hey, das ist ein Pentium 2 400 mit 16 MB Grafikkarte blablabla
die Möglichkeit war es das schlechteste vom schlechtesten und das Lowendigste vom Lowendigste, hauptsache man konnte große Zahlen draufschreiben.
Das gibt es ja aber schon immer und du kriegst dann das was du da im Endeffekt kaufst, wenn du dich verarschen lässt.
Aber ansonsten, wenn du 3000 Euro für einen Gaming Notebook ausgibst, wenn du den Gaming Notebooks kaufst, da werden die meisten Leute schon Tests lesen.
Es geht doch keiner in den Mediamarkt und sagt, gib mir ein 3000 Euro Gaming Notebook.
Doch, doch, gibt es vielleicht schon, aber trotzdem, selbst dann verstehe ich nicht, was der Hersteller davon hat.
Letztendlich ist die Performance das, was einen zufriedenen Gaming Notebook Käufer ausmacht.
Aber wie gesagt, man kann das ganze ja ganz einfach umgehen, einfach RGB-RAM kaufen.
Und für was? So, dass sie vielleicht ein paar Dollar bezahlen können?
Ich meine, es ist nicht so, wie diese Produzenten, die gute Sachen auf New Egg für etwa 45 Dollar pro Stick bekommen.
Also, was genau passiert hier?
Na, ich werde es dir so erklären, wie du fünf bist.
Frag doch mal!
Er könnte ja manchmal den Herstellern fragen, könnte er sagen, na, warum? Erzähl mal.
Die würden ihm bestimmt Antworten und so irgendein Schwubbelzeug ausdenken.
Die haben eine Küche im Studio, weil er früher in der Küche Videos aufgenommen hat.
Oh, BigBrain erklärt.
BigBrain.
Deswegen guckt man sich Tests an, bevor man was kauft.
Und wenn du es nicht machst, bist du einfach doof?
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Okay.
Äh.
Wa-
Wa- warum?
Wahrscheinlich weil's billiger ist.
Okay, ja, le- leuchtet ein.
Wie routet man eine Grafikkarte eigentlich durch die andere? Die haben doch in der Regel keine Input.
Einfach dranlöten.
Beste.
Ich kaufe nur RGB-RAM.
Das ist witzigerweise gerade ein RAM, den ich drin hab.
Okay.
Das einfache- Leute, Leute.
Das einfache ist doch ganz klar.
Wenn man sich für was kaufen will, dann sucht man sich einfach einen Test raus und nimmt sich das, was vom Preis-Leistungs-mäßig und den Ergebnissen einem am besten zusagt.
So schwierig ist das doch alles nicht.
Nur, dass man damit nicht spielen kann.
Okay, super.
Also ja, ich versteh den Punkt von ihm schon, dass das ersichtlich sein sollte, aber ich seh da jetzt nicht die große- das Riesenproblem drin.
Letztendlich ist das doch schon immer so gewesen, wenn du was kaufen willst, guckst du dir- machst du dich vorher ein bisschen schlau.
Und wenn du es nicht machst, dann musst du ja auch nicht wundern, an der Kacke kaufst.
Naja.
Du könntest doch eigentlich den Reaction-Channel auf YouTube machen, oder hast du? Nee, was soll ich da machen? Großartig.
Oder? Was, was? Jetzt, also erstens, erstens, Problem ist, Problem ist, wenn ich, wenn ich reakte, dann reakte ich ja hier im Stream.
Das heißt, ich müsste danach den Kram irgendwie zusammenschneiden für YouTube.
Außerdem, das Allerwichtigste, ich brauch, ich brauch unbedingt endlich meinen 3D animierten Kicks.
Dass ich, dass ich endlich, dass ich wenigstens Mund auf und zu mache, ja.
Für Reaction-Videos, sonst ist das doch langweilig, da muss irgendwas im Bild sein.
Jailor, cuttet ihr das für 3,50? Ja, wenn er das macht, easy, dann gebt, dem geb ich sogar, dem geb ich sogar 35,50 dann.
Leistes Monatsgehalt.
Ich, ich mach da, ich mach da, mach da ein V-Tubing-Reaction. Alter, wenn das, das geht durch die Decke, ich sag's euch.
Braucht er noch einen Anime-Style-Kicks-Avatar?
Cute, cute, Reaction.
Aktuell machen die ja Reaction-Videos zu Reaction-Videos, ja, ja, ja.
Wir haben ja auch Videos schon Reacted, wo einer auf jemand Reacted hat, der Reacted hat, das war eine richtig krasse Reaction.
React, Re-Acception war das.
Du, du, du, du.
So, gucken wir jetzt noch was, ich hab übelst Hunger, Leute. Massive Kohldampf, ja.
Jetzt, ich, ich speichere mir das jetzt mal fürs nächste.
Moment.
Bookmark, Bookmark, Tabs.
Neuer Folder vom 27.06.2021.
Irgendwas hab ich hier falsch gemacht gerade.
Ah, meine Bookmarks, Alter. Nee, passt doch, ist doch hier.
Exzellent.
Super, super organisierte Bookmarks.
Und übersetzt mir Twitch gerade in Chat auf Englisch, ernsthaft, macht's das? Wusste ich nicht, dass es geht für den Browser-Plugin von dir.
Leute, ich hab Hunger. Ich geh jetzt was essen. Wir sehen uns, vielleicht heute Abend schon wieder.
Bis nächste Woche, bis denn. Macht's gut, see you.